be call 1 800 CC and 98 for pricing
information and to request a tape now in
depth with author Joan Didion these are
the books written by journalist essayist
and author Joan Didion between 1963 and
1996 v or fiction v or nonfiction Joan
Didion is also written articles and book
reviews for publications including the
New York Review of Books
she's also co-authored seven screenplays
with her husband nominated for the
National Book Award both in 1971 and
again in 1981 our guest this month for
in-depth is Joan Didion welcome thank
you
first let's go back to 1963 hmm you were
29 years old if I did my math right I
was 28 I didn't get to be 29 till
December and so 28 years old
run river isn't published what was it
like well it taken me five years to
write it because I was working and I was
working I had a job I was living in New
York I was working for a magazine vogue
and so I was writing this at night and
finally I got about halfway through it
and I realized I just couldn't finish it
writing at night because when you get
halfway through a book it comes a time
when you have to concentrate on it and
pull it together and a couple of hours
twice a week you know it was basically
what you have at night because you've
also got off are you've got other
obligations you have to go when I was
headed I was covering cultural events
for Logan so I had to go to a play or
something was not going to finish this
book so finally I have took a couple of
months or three weeks or a month leave
of absence or something and went home to
Sacramento and just typed finish finish
the book and so the big relief when it
came out I mean it was it was it was a
huge relief to me when it came out how
many books did you written previously
guys that had not been published oh I
didn't know no I'd never written another
book nothing
no no rejections no no I mean
that work when I can take a leave of
absence I needed some money to support
myself but that month right over two
months so I stand it around to
publishers I got turned down by 12
publishers yes definitely there are
rejections but the 13th took it and - I
don't know I mean it I don't I don't
know how anybody gets through that phase
of being rejected all the time but you
do I mean that's part of what you do
this was fiction did you think at the
time that there would anything be
anything but fiction or was this or was
the fiction of the difference I had
always wanted one when I was in school I
wanted to write to snow um and so I
hadn't thought of doing nonfiction I
didn't actually start I started then I
started after that book was published I
left vogue and started writing pieces
for magazines to support myself and then
I put them you know started putting
those together and sometimes you would
hit a piece that seems that could take a
longer length and then a magazine could
give you and I think I might do a
nonfiction book someday but I didn't do
one for a long time
gonna jump way ahead to your most recent
non-fiction series of essays called
after Henry first of all half how did
the title title I'm about they were I
had an editor at him well first he
wasn't very Strauss then he went to the
Simon & Schuster and I went with him he
died he dropped dead in a subway station
you know at age 49 or 50 and I was so
dependent on him and I thought I could
never write again I mean it was I was
devastated and a lot of people who are
he ended it or said well I know several
other people here did felt just as
devastated at the time
is normal for writers in the
relationship with their editors I think
in some cases it is it wasn't nobody
understood really what nobody
understands what he wouldn't editor does
I mean an editor doesn't sit there with
a blue pencil but they give you the idea
that you can do it somehow they transmit
that to you without without saying
without without making it sound like
some kind of dumb pep talk you know but
they seemed they believed in you
this book was literally after Henry was
after Henry yeah who became your head of
direct in it Michael kurta at Simon and
Schuster was my editor then and then and
no Shelley Ranger at Knopf was my editor
we jump into the one of your pieces here
it's called insider baseball and of
course it's about politics because
that's where we talk a lot about here
you begin this way it occurred to me
during the summer of 1988 in California
and Atlanta and New Orleans in the
course of watching first the California
primary and then the Democratic and
Republican national conventions that had
not been by accident but the people with
whom I had preferred to spend time in
high school had on the whole hung out in
gas stations mm-hmm does that say more
about you or more about the Democratic
and Republican convention well probably
both welcome I had I had never covered
American politics
I had never it simply was outside my
whole interest range I what I wasn't
interested in it bob silvers at the New
York Review asked me to cover the 88
campaign and I kept you know in theory I
knew Utley something I should do and I
in theory I was going to do it but I
kept putting it off I I clipped
everything I think in a fire I had these
I had files all over the house of every
single clipping from every single
newspaper we got on a skewer days and
obscure
you know um I didn't actually do
anything until June when I had to go to
California for some reason some other
reason and Bob said fine then we'll
we'll arrange for you to go out with
Jesse Jackson and so I did and then I
did other than I did something with a
Dukakis campaign but it was something I
did some wonder stuff but and I did the
conventions but I had never ever been
exposed before to the process of
American politics and you talk a lot
about those new words about process yeah
it was it was it was it was quite
stunning to me what was what was the
stunning part well it seemed to it
seemed to exist it seemed to maintain
exist only to maintain itself I mean it
didn't seem to have any relationship
with the people who hung around gas
station it didn't seem to connect with
the rest of the country and what we saw
that in a fairly dramatic way you know
over the past a couple of years I mean
we thought what what became known as the
disconnect became pretty clear uh but
this was you could see the disconnect in
a campaign I mean you could see it in
the campaign very clearly it seemed to
me you wrote a little bit in the same in
the same one of same essay about the
pressure that was on Michael Dukakis in
the 1988 convention to make the speech
of his lifetime and that he was supposed
to come out there and make this speech
and everybody it had to be different it
had to be the right one and you say in
here the David Broder and others after
the speech had said this was it this was
it he really hit it out of the ballpark
but then you say you say the critics
raved about it but in reality it was
because it was good because the floor
had been darkened swept with laser beams
and flooded with coming to America
played at concert volume with a bass
turned mm-hmm yeah and it really
wouldn't have mattered of what the
speech was it wouldn't have mattered I
mean the pressure wasn't on Dukakis so
much the pressure that we've been the
narrative was already in place I mean
the candidate always makes believe me
this summer it'll happen twice speech of
his life as a at that moment you like
the covering of politics I wipe out you
mean do I like the politics as it is
covered no I actually won do I like I
doing and when you go to write about it
yeah I do I always resist it still but
and I don't do it very often but um when
I when I finally get shoved into facing
I don't like it one of your essays and I
think I'm going to have to go to the
White Album to find it and this would
have been at what period so why album I
think those pieces are they're about the
60s they're sort of in the late sixties
early seventies and it's called the
White Album because now the Beatles
album which was which was which was the
album that was which was figured in a
Manson trial it was it was it was a kind
of dark column and a lot of this stuff
that was the period was I am going to
move to that because I want to make a
connection between what you talked about
it was reporting of political life with
what you saw in women reporters a little
bit earlier and you tell a story in here
about going to Nancy Reagan's house when
she was the first lady of California and
that there was a television crew there I
want to read just a little bit of it and
have you tell more the story usually the
television crew wanted to watch her the
newsman said while she was doing
precisely what she would ordinarily be
doing on a Tuesday morning at home since
I was there to watch her doing precisely
what she would ordinarily be doing on a
Tuesday morning at home we seem to be on
the verge of exploring certain media
frontiers the television news man in the
to cameraman could watch Nancy Reagan
being watched by me or I could watch
Nancy Reagan be mwah
by the three of them or one of the
cameraman could step back into a cinema
verite study and the rest of us watching
and being watched by one another I have
the distinct I had the distinct sense
that we were on the track of something
revelatory yeah it was a really
ridiculous day but is that somewhat
pressing into what we see today
well is it well it was I mean it was it
was I mean I don't know why I was so
stunned in 1988 to see the number of see
the number of staged events that were
staged and totally for the moment you
know so that they would be broadcast
right because there it was and Nancy
Reagan was doing the same thing in her
own back yard on 45th Street with
Sacramento she was pretending to pick
flowers for the television crew and okay
it was it was it it was exactly the same
yes Joan Didion is going to be with us
for three hours today and in about 15
minutes we're going to open up our phone
lines give you an opportunity to talk to
her our phone lines are divided between
East Coast and West Coast free as you
live in the East or Central time zone
two oh two six two four eleven eleven if
you live in the mountain or Pacific time
zone two oh two six two four eleven
fifteen and again we'll start taking
your calls in about 15 minutes do you do
this very often when men talk about your
writing now I don't I did it some when
my last novel came out and I think the
time before that when I do it with a
couple of books before that I mean I
don't really don't do it are you
comfortable talking about your own
writing do you like to oh I don't mind
talking about it I don't talk about
anything that I haven't done yet I mean
I won't I don't talk about anything I'm
working on or thinking about in the
preface to this foreign which was
flashing toward best towards Bethlehem
published 1968 you wrote almost all of
the pieces here this is also a
collection of essays here were written
for magazines during 1965 66 67 and most
of them to get that question out of the
way at the onset where my idea do you
get that question a lot yeah I mean
people want to know if it because a
certain piece was the
his idea or your idea I don't know why I
don't really cuz it really doesn't
matter whose idea it was
it just is because you wouldn't do it if
an integer suggested something if it
wasn't if you didn't respond to
something but these were pieces that I
was doing basically I was living in Los
Angeles and the magazine's I was writing
for were in New York and so I was doing
I was reporting on a lot of stuff that
they weren't seeing so it was so they
were my idea and where does the title
come from it comes from that Yeats poem
you know turning and turning in the
widening gyre when what rough beast
slouches toward Bethlehem to be born
which was something that had come to my
mind when I was doing a piece in the
Haight Ashbury in 1967 and and it seemed
to me that it was that we were seeing
the tip of something important that
wasn't about quote-unquote hippies you
know that it was about disaffected a
whole disinfect disaffected children
etcetera how I get to go to that if I
can and read just a little bit of that
so people can hear a little bit about
what you wrote about 1967 and your
thoughts about it the center was not
holding it was a country of bankruptcy
notices and public option announcements
and commonplace reports of casual
killings and misplaced children and
abandoned homes and vandals who
misspelled even the four-letter words
they scrawled it was a country in which
families routinely disappeared trailing
bad checks and repossession papers
adolescents drifted from city to torn
City sloughing off both the past in the
future as snakes shed their skins
children were never taught and would
never know would never now learn the
games they had held that had held a
suspect the society together people were
missing children were missing parents
were missing those left behind file
death Latorre
missing
and reports then moved on themselves
pretty depressing look at 1967 yeah it
is
and was how it fell so where were you I
was in Los Angeles I mean it was in
business at that whole period the 60s we
record we're a whole there was a lot of
upheaval going on I mean besides the
kind of obvious of people there was a
lot of social upheaval
I always thought at some level the 60s
were came out of the fact that we hadn't
yet accommodated the we hadn't really
accommodated the end of the industrial
revolution I mean it was sort of we
started trying to do it we started
trying to do in the 60s um it was it's a
lot of upheaval um a lot of interesting
people during that time I had a list of
them here so here we Newton I did a
piece about Huey Newton you know and I'm
trying to remember some of the other
people that you had forced on during
that time worker you know did pieces on
or mad you talked about some rock singer
yeah I see amorous and I get a piece on
oh we're on the door you get into that
world call that somebody I just went
over to sunset down which is where they
were recording which was nearer Clarke
where we were then living it was it was
you know you just dissipate with it's
actually the hardest thing to do as a
reporter or I always found it make that
call but if you do make the call sooner
or later you're on in the scene did you
like to see yeah I mean I always I like
to sit around and watch people do what
they do I don't like to ask questions
I don't particularly like to I hate
doing interviews I mean right as the
interviewer I would rather just didn't
watch people do a sell rock and roll
people are in many ways the ideal
subject for me because they will just
lead their lives in front of you they
will able to say well rehearsed they
will play they will they will do
whatever they're doing so that was that
that was perfectly easy here's some
other people I know Janis Joplin um I
never did a piece on Janis Joplin I did
know I mean I had met her up she was a
friend of some friends of ours Huey
Newton Eldridge Cleaver called Reed
Cleaver was basically running the P Way
was in jail Eldridge Cleaver was
basically the person you got in touch
with if you wanted to see Huey Newton at
that time it was or it was to me I plus
the lawyer but when you write in the
White Album that you just called him up
and went over to South yeah he wasn't
that happen today she was living in San
Francisco there's some oh and it still
could happen I mean did you have to go
through TVs were not that let those
these were not these names now found on
legendary but they weren't legendary at
that they weren't they weren't legend at
that moment if you see what I think they
were just people who were in the middle
of a situation did you have feeling a
feeling that they would become figure
named well yeah I did um yurui Newton
was already a big name you wrote in one
of your essays about the 60s that many
people believe the 60s ended on August 9
1969 what happened that was the night of
the Manson killings
the night of the Cielo Cielo Drive which
was the Sharon Tate
voytek frykowski
and the other people who were killed at
that at that house and you but you say
in a sense for you the end of the 60s
didn't come till January 1971 what
happened then we moved from we've been
living in a house in Hollywood with a
manor house it was a wonderful falling
down house which which Adjara noise it
felt like that period to me and then we
moved out to to the code we moved out to
the far end of Malibu and Trancas and it
was very different kind of life I mean
it was it was it was just a new kind of
life it was like we were living on the
frontier that were what impact social
impact do you think the Manson murders
had them on the United State well it I
don't know that what impact they had on
the United States they were quite
devastating in Los Angeles because
because it because you know when it
first happened I think everybody tried
to think that it was in some way
couldn't happen just couldn't have
happened to them because they weren't
those people right but it could have
happened to anyone it could have
happened and I think that by the time
but by the time that you know the whole
thing played out I think I think that
was what was so frightening and
devastating to everybody one of the I
remember talking I just I interviewed
Linda cassabi and it was the driver on
both night that they killed and
the second when the second night was I
mean the picking of the address seemed
perfectly random you know uh it didn't
could have out it could have been
anybody
he wanted the essays that you've written
more recently that got a lot of
attention was the rape in Central Park
what year was that I can't remember what
year it was off and it was he was in the
early 90s early nineteen you make any
comparisons between the two now that was
a basically that was a different kind of
thing my interest in the in that
intimate can this was this is the case
that we came in as the Central Park
jogger in case nobody remembers but but
my actual interest in that case was in
that was in the reaction of the tabloid
press in New York and and been peepin
not just the tabloid press the press in
general the the way in which we get to
get accommodated certain cause in
terminal ideas that New York out of
itself whereas the well in a way the
Madison killings
satisfied certain apocalyptic guys there
certain local and a mental ideas I means
I indicate there was a sentimental idea
in one of those in the 60s it involves
epochal it want to here's a quote from
here extra it was a pretty extended
essay about you said it was I just I had
been going to write I had been
interested because we had just moved to
New York a few years before and I really
didn't understand that I mean I lived
there when I got out of college but I
was back after twenty-five years in Los
Angeles and I didn't really quite get it
you know I mean I wasn't I wasn't
I didn't understand a lot of things
things about why it was the way we were
the way it was so I was going to do a
series of pieces on reporting pieces in
New York and then I did this piece and
it went on for so long I mean I just got
got the whole thing on I lost interest
and because I sort of got it there you
wrote criminal cases are widely regarded
by American reporters as windows on the
city or culture in which they take place
opportunities to enter not only
households but parts of the culture
normally closed and yet this was a case
in which indifference to the world of
the defendants extended even to the
reporting of names and occupations
meanness mania where they kept getting I
mean nobody could quite get one of the
defendants mother who was quite present
in the at the time of the trial because
she was attractive she was she was there
but they but everybody got her name or
everybody misspelled her name
differently and not only anybody spelled
it the way the same way she spelled it
and then she was she had a she was given
a series of different occupations you
know I mean these are things that are
pretty easy to find out if you just
actually look into it I mean that in
business there was but I don't think
this was a question of sloppy reporting
so much I think it was a question it was
one of those cases in which her story
whatever her story was or how her name
was spelled didn't fit into the
narrative that was being but inches of
into into the narrative of the story
there was a there was a story in place
and she didn't in some way I fit fit
into it do you remember when you first
started writing I started writing when I
was quite moral I mean before before i
when i was writing stories when i was
before i had before you know one point
you know when i was five or six
do you write in here someplace that your
mother handed you a tablet and said go
write something yeah was he not whining
around about being bored or something
and she said she gave me a big five
tablet and told me to go write something
and so I did and it was a it was an
apocalyptic kind of story about somebody
who was a woman who finds herself
freezing to death in the Arctic and then
she finally would leave comes and then
she would heat comes and then she
realizes that what she's now she's now
dying of heat in the tropics and I may
have been vice versa I don't remember
but whatever way it was that there was
this is a no out of no out situation for
this woman you wrote this at age I was
five or six yeah mm-hmm do you remember
your mother's reactions no no I don't
they think it was an unusual thing for a
five year olds right I don't know I was
doing I was probably doing five year
olds you know who I think if it was a
character my mother had been a librarian
before she was married but when she was
married when she was 24 so that was not
and then then I was born so she was home
I mean at that time and that my father
was during the Depression so when he
when when I was first born he had a
eight he he was selling insurance but he
was also supporting but nobody was
buying anything so he was he would
support play poker and do stuff you know
he's and
during the war he was in the she was in
the Army Air Corps and after the war and
he was he was it was it was kind of a
big boom time in California and he was
buying and selling real estate basically
you know buying real estate selling it
at a profit and then and then the during
the Korean War his the reserve unit was
reactivated and he went back into and
was enormous and I don't know what
service it was at that point I guess was
the Air Force any brothers and sisters I
have a brother a younger brother yes who
was with the Corps who is the chairman
of a commercial real estate company
looking for a oh here it is one of the
essays you wrote in slouching towards
Bethlehem in which you talk in which is
called erode at 1967 and it was called
on going home and you mention your
family and then we just wanted to read a
little bit and get you have you talked
about you say sometimes I think that
those of us who are now in our 30s you
know at the emphases in 1957 were born
into the last generation to carry the
burden of home to find in family life
the source of all tension and drama I
had by all objective accounts a normal
and a happy family situation and yet I
was almost thirty years old before I
could talk to my family on the telephone
without crying after I had hung up we
did not fight nothing was wrong and yet
some nameless anxiety colored the
emotional charges between me and the
place that I came from the question of
whether or not you could go home again
was a very real part of the sentimental
and largely literary baggage with which
we left home in the 50s I suspect that
it is irrelevant to the children born of
the fragmentation after World War two I
was mistaken
it's not irrelevant
I learned that a sixth exam yeah what
did you learn climate I learned that
that the same kind of family dramas
afflict them that afflicted us so how
did you learn to talk to have a child
talk to her talk to her friends I'm
eating a watch tell us about your
daughter she's 30 she's her early 30s
she's a she's a great which her name is
Quinn Clint aniruddha and Jana where did
you get the name her father and I were
in Mexico not in Quintana row but in
another part of Mexico and I was looking
at a map and I thought how beautiful
this name was it was still a territory
then and I never known anyone had been
there I'm mrs. before all the stuff and
so we and Not long afterwards we adopted
quintonk and we call quintile we act
slightly anglicized the pronunciation
because it was easier for everybody and
and we named her there and it was it was
a very romantic idea to me then because
it was still with terra incognita it was
it was totally it was a wild flight and
then immediately after she was born it
became a state in the declivity with a
Club Med it was Cancun only
archaeologists and herpetologist went
there at that you know before what did
she do
felony she's a photographer and she's a
right now she's a photo editor at Elle
Decor magazine what does she think of
your writing over the years she puts up
with it what is there to put up with
well I mean I think it's always a little
I think for anybody in
your family it's probably like a little
embarrassing they have a parent or a
sister or daughter out there being in
public you know or saying things are
writing down which is which she feels or
you know I think it's probably not an
ideal situation for other people
how'd she handle it she handled it
beautifully
we're talking about Joan Didion and
she's our guest this month on in depth
we're going to put up our phone lines
again for the eastern central time zone
202 624 1111 if you live in the mountain
or Pacific time zone 202 624 1115 we'll
start taking our first call first call
us from Washington DC miss Vivian it's a
pleasure to talk to you I wanted to ask
you you once wrote a story about for a
magazine I believe and it may be in one
of your collections about John Wayne and
it was towards the end of his film
career would you describe a little bit
that story and the circumstances of your
meeting with him and what you think now
in the year 2000 of his place in
American culture and then I have maybe
one question to ask you after that this
was a piece idea I think was 1965 and he
already had camp had had cancer he went
he was making a picture in Mexico called
the sons of Katie elder and went down
and he was it it was just it was you
know it was what what writers call a
set-piece you go onto the stat you you
write the you know you write what goes
on on the set and so I did and was it
you know it was it was a sort of amazing
larger-than-life figure and he was still
larger than life even even even sick
you round in here when John Wayne roads
from my childhood and perhaps through
yours he determined forever the shape of
certain of our dreams
mm-hmm-hmm I still felt that about him
when I'm ready what's the second part of
your question Fowler Washington much the
second part of your question yes can you
hear me okay yes Kenny the the writer
the California writer Ben Stein has
acknowledged you in a number of his of
his books as sort of an inspiration and
mentor of sorts and I was wondering if
you could please sort of describe your
relationship with him and what you think
of his writing van is a brand I mean
he's really a a good friend I mean I
adore him um sad herb Stein the economy
Diaz yes he lives in California we used
to he worked for tea
I first met him II was working for the
White House he was sort of junior
speechwriter and the Nixon
administration's you agree with him
politically we don't agree both
politically uh we don't talk so much
about politics but I don't think we
probably agree politically huh what do
you think of his writing like Ben
Stein's diary that he writes in life is
weird I just I I see I hadn't been
seeing the American sector guys excited
and just read it a couple of issues back
and I don't loved it is that but it
sound exactly like talking to Ben
Hollywood you're next hello hi it's Eve
Eve how are you I'm I and II who are you
I'm Eve Babbitt's a friend of hers from
Hollywood and when I I wanted to just
say how great it is to see your on the
air
well II thank you neither what to ask
you used to come to that house at that
old house in Hollywood yeah yeah the
first time I ever saw Spode China what
is that in English joint you know
and it was it was amazing to me because
you seem to be like the only you know
sensible person in the whole world in
those days well in what way well you
could make dinner for 40 people without
you know with one hand tied behind your
back and things like that whereas
everybody else was sort of passed out on
the floor you know well organization was
very important to me at that time
Baltimore Maryland you're next hello
you're on the air sir go ahead yes I am
having lived in Sacramento for a number
of years in the big fan of your first
novel run river and thank you notes of a
native daughter is still widely read
there in fact every woman writer I meet
in Sacramento wants to write like Joan
Didion I wonder if you've been back to
Sacramento recently and we know what you
make of it
I meant years later I haven't been back
recently because my parents moved to
Monterey in 1988 and my brother lives
there too and so I so that's where I
tend to go instead of to Sac well I
still have a lot of cousins in
Sacramento but I see them at in Monterey
rather than in Sacramento
what's this novel the last thing he
wanted the last thing he wanted was my
plot novel it was my novel about
iran-contra but I mean it's very heavily
plotted it was so heavily plotted that I
had to write it in one sitting
you know when you put I would lose the
track of the plot if I if I if I didn't
just sit down and do it and if I if I
went out to dinner I practically lost
track of the plot it was a really quiet
so how long did it take you to do the
whole thing well I see I've been writing
bits of it and taking and making doing
parts of it but then when I actually sat
down to write it I did it between the
end of August and the end of December of
one year
and so it was a very concentrated
concentrated effort the light was he was
it was it was fun actually it was it was
a good way a good way to work this is
what your most recent work yeah and when
I say was my iran-contra novel II just
basically came out of all those events
and I tradition fiction bleed into non
fiction or nonfiction between into
fiction they see I think they think that
the nonfiction bleeds into fiction quite
a bit although I had never I don't
except in Miami I had never actually
written about around contra but of
course those events were all that
mutates I mean Miami was fused with them
at the time I was there which was 1985
and this is a this is the book not in
the nonfiction book Miami you know again
a serious a question of your essays came
out when in general it came out in 87
but I was I was there in 85 and 86 next
call for Joan Didion is from Upland
California
Joan Moines I wanted to say about your
book monster was very honest depiction
of the whole motion picture industry
that's my husband's book well you
mentioned you quite a lot yeah and the
main point is I am from an area of
course you made rather infamous and your
essay dreamers are the golden dream and
you know what that whole case overrun
banging Street and you know yeah I
wanted to the two questions I had is
like you've seen have predated a lot of
the obsession a weird crime that we have
in the
with the Bobbitt's and all that kind of
thing with that essay and you ever found
out what happened to those people I have
I believe that Lucille Miller she's
served her term and I believe that she
is dead now
the daughters grew up I've talked to one
of them she's a lovely woman and that's
and that's all I know
do you like true crime stories well
crime stories do every for a reporter or
a writer they do give you a way into
into people's lives I mean I remember
once I was working for a it's always
been a problem for me to actually think
of calling somebody up and think and I
come into your life and and write about
you there has to be some some public
event for me to do it I mean I remember
once I was working for life for a very
short time and I was looking for I said
to the managing into the then managing
editor I wanted I was I would like to do
such and such a kind of piece but I
couldn't find a way in and I couldn't
find an event to take me into it and he
said don't be ridiculous you just call
him weapons and you call up and you say
I'm from life whether that was the way
people thought but I couldn't quite do
that he thought it was it wasn't you it
was intrusive I don't think anybody
gains a great deal from having a
reporter or a writer in their life I
think that I wrote a line once which a
lot of people misinterpreted and it was
in the introduction to sloshing toward
Bethlehem and the line was writers were
always telling somebody out and a lot of
people took that I mean almost
universally it was taken to mean that
you are deliberate with the writer is
deliberately betraying the that's not
what happens what happens is the writer
sees the subject in a different way from
the subject way the subjects to use him
or herself but people who are not public
figures people who have not dealt with
with public persona have generally don't
have a very developed idea of what their
poem of how they transmit themself of
how they look to other people but
there's no there's nothing wrong with
this it just it's just the way they they
get they get and whether it's whether
the reporter is is sympathetic and love
them no matter what that what's the
report no matter how positive the
reporter's reaction may be it is
different from the way they view
themselves and that they that that feels
as if something has been taken away from
your privacy whatever so yeah so I find
it intrusive to go into people's life
there's more in that process I want to
get into because you talked a lot about
how you feel about the whole area of
reporting and interviewing people and
such and towards Bethlehem but let's
take this call from New Orleans next
hello New Orleans hello joining the show
I have a question about the Central Park
jogger case that was talked about a
little bit back I speak out of the
context of being a political cartoonist
and having been a managing editor of a
newspaper in my lifetime
one I'm a cartoonist right now and you
said that one of the mothers of the
defendant sought the mother of the
defendant constantly had her name
misspelled and nobody could find out
really well which he did for a living
they kept changing it or what have you
and you said that that wasn't sloppy
reporting I'm sorry what is sloppy
reporting to you if you can't do
something as simple as that
on an important story oh no I didn't
mean that it wasn't sloppy reporting I
think it was but I didn't think that
derived but it was just I was more than
just sloppiness I thought that it
derived from a from from basically
having a having a having another story
to tell and her she didn't fit into it
that's what is then allowing yourself
the then they allowed themselves to get
sloppy the essay is called sentimental
journeys it can be found in Joan
Didion's most recent non-fiction book
which is called after Henry and I want
to go back into it a little bit more and
ask you about this page 262 you say this
the fact that neither the victim's
family nor later the victim herself
wanted her name known strucked an
immediate court of sympathy seemed a
belated way to protect her as she had
not been protected in Central Park
yet there was in this case a special
emotional undertow that derived in part
from the deep and elusive associations
and taboos attracting in American black
history to the idea of the rape of white
women rape remained in collective memory
of many blacks the very core of their
victimization yeah and it became a
question of not naming the Central Park
jogger became a huge issue in New York
and it became its because it was quite
an ugly situation where she was named
actually she was named in black papers
she was named in on black it all through
the black media book sobs in New York
the local black media she was not named
in the white media
which it was quite an ugly situation and
there's a lot of seemingly false
righteousness on the part of rights
about a whites about not naming her in
fact I mean I a strong feeling about it
I had a lot of strong feelings about it
and one of my feeling it didn't have to
do with the white black issue but it had
to do with which was just that wasn't it
this exacerbation of a situation that
was it's always not very far below the
surface in New York but my own feeling
about not naming her was that it in a
way it reduced her humanity what
happened to her what I mean the hurt the
damage that was done to her was so much
greater than the rape I mean she had you
know pipe shoved into her head and and
she was she she was simply brutalized
but it wasn't it was it was much more
than the rate and this put all the
emphasis on the rape she was not named
as a rape victim right and the other
things were so much graver next call is
from San Francisco hello hello Joan I'm
such a pleasure to be able to talk with
you I'm fortunately I haven't read any
of your books and I'm writing them all
down as they appear on television
because I'm going to that's on my things
of you know lists of things to do but
the question is you mentioned 1967 and
what came to me initially I thought you
were going to talk about perhaps the
impact of the six-day war did that in
any way affect you did you write
anything about that no I didn't write
anything about it I hadn't I didn't
actually go to Israel until much much
later and didn't write anything then my
husband did
you did write this non-fiction book from
a trip to El Salvador my DNA on trips
shows 82 what did you why what did you
write in this book Salvador well I went
down because it was one of those
situations where you were reading stuff
in the paper and didn't quite see
official statements on it didn't quite
add up
and as I was so we thought we would just
go down and see what was going on and I
mean it was a it I didn't come to any
overwhelming conclusion about it except
that we were except that we were lying
about I mean except that there was there
was except that the government was
diluting it was the United States
government was deluding himself about
his role there I mean it was just a
simple you go down you report that's all
that's all that's all I was doing there
was like a it was a very straightforward
book
this is nonfiction very a very small but
very thin book how did the decision come
to decide to put this reporting into
book form yeah I did it for the New York
Review I did it it ran in three part and
I don't know whose idea it was whether
it was Simon & Schuster's or whoever
whoever it was it came it was it was
quite it was very it was produced very
fast was produced almost like a pamphlet
I was hardcover I went down to El
Salvador in June these pieces appeared
in the New York Review in the fall and
in the first of April I think there was
a book was on the bed of the New York
Times bestseller so that was it was a
very fast
it was a very gratifying thing to be
able to write something topical and have
it produced that fast you know it's one
problem with
with a book business that doesn't work
fast did you have any feeling that what
you wrote in Salvador had any hand in
Hamden Act none none none zero yeah it
was on the bestseller list people were
obviously reading and yes they were but
I was discouraged it was discouraging
and according to gob viously didn't
change that was 1982 it was published in
the spring of 83 we were still there I
mean we were still did any politicians
call you want to talk to you about what
you found
no one aid to to a congressman who said
to me when I was introduced to him a
couple of years later it says said that
book was that said Salvador was very
useful to us at a point at a certain
point Austin Texas you're next hello go
ahead often to get a chance to speak
with miss Vivian I first came in contact
with your writing after seeing an
American Playhouse production of play it
as it lays and it had such a profound
impact on me with its just straight
ahead and really razor-sharp writing or
what have you and I really don't have a
question but I've read most of your
novels and the one that has really stuck
with me is the slouching towards
Bethlehem to where I can think of most
of the stories essays in there and when
you talk about walking through a
revolving door and coming out a good
deal later at 28 I believe I've lived in
both New York and California and I've
read many novels and I just wanted to
again not gush because I know you
wouldn't really like that but I really
haven't come across any woman writer who
writes with those straight ahead and
the razor sharp focus that you have and
thank you I appreciate them and I just I
wish you well and thanks for giving me
the opportunity to say that thank you
for calling what do you what do you
think people mean when they say they
like your razor-sharp writing I think
that I think people are responding to
certain directness of a voice which I
can which I think the old man is a good
deal better on paper than I do that I do
actually in person I mean I don't come
across in a very direct person but I but
off but I try to be drunk I get direct
on the face what is there between the
mind and the fingers going into however
you write that helps you clarify that I
don't know it's just been that's what
that's that's the place where you stay
honest you know and where you talk I'll
I mean you know it was a very you always
have a very specific I don't mean a
specific reader but you have a very
specific idea that so that you want to
tell somebody something that's why
you're writing it down you want to you
want to transmit this this isn't in a
vacuum I'm not writing things on a piece
of paper should be preserved on so that
you know in a safe deposit box of if I
wouldn't do it if nobody read it it
wouldn't it's not for me
so that's so this is you're aware of
that back to the west coast know we
think means to keep going back and forth
between the east and west coast which is
kind of what you like for some use this
once in Los Angeles go ahead oh hello
Jill yes Andy sturgeon hello sandy how
are you how are you very well thank you
I just wanted to remind you yes when you
add the next to you on Franklin yeah and
the first time that I met you I had met
you formally at all and one day there
was a great knock upon the door because
of not the sign on my door said knock
loudly and I came to the door and there
was this little third
and a half year old little girl and I
thought oh how charming she's come to
play with my boys turned out she was a
grown up and a delightful girl and Joe
yes would it be possible could you take
off your glasses yes I know wait a
minute yes but because I wanted
everybody to see what beautiful eyes Oh
Danny thank you that you had such
sparkling eyes really little girl the
wee little girl frame I mean she was a
tiny G I was coming to I was coming to
hire your boys as a babysitter
and guess what my son Tom learned did to
your home while you were not away and he
was babysitting Queen Donna what he
stole three cigarettes and he has been
smoking ever since ah are the glasses a
signature for you I feel more
comfortable yeah up with money you can
leave them on take them up whatever
you're more comfortable I want to quote
something from from the preface that you
were talking about earlier because it
has to do with here your physical size
and your previous neighbor talked about
that you say my only advantage is a
reporter is that I am so physically
small so temperamental e unobtrusive and
so neurotically and articulate the
people tend to forget that my presence
runs counter to their best interests and
of course that was a sentence higher to
the one writers are always selling
somebody in mmm-hmm so your physical
size has helped you over the years well
in that sense yeah I mean it's much
easier I'm not very threatening on the
other hand it's very hard if you're in a
certain kind of situation like like
people also don't take me seriously so
that that is that's good if I just want
to hang around you know and don't want
them to notice me but it but but it
would be hard if I wanted to interview
them say if I wanted to if I wanted to
command their attention and respect
it's very hard at my sauce in deficit
spending three hours with Joan Didion
one hours already gone next called New
York City
go ahead
I I just wanted to say animus Didion I
love her books particularly the White
Album and slouching towards Bethlehem
and was wondering what her thoughts were
on Hillary Clinton and her candidacy in
New York because she seems to possess
such penetrating insight to people their
motivations and their drives I was just
wondering if she had any thoughts to
what this was I having actually a lot of
great deal about about that campaign I
uh I may be thinking about it you know
it over the summer or something but I'm
not but I have but I've kind of been
holding it up at somewhere off enough in
an ante room if I'm correct your most
recent magazine pieces the piece from
The New Yorker that piece I did on
Martha Stewart that's right uh February
and the devil issue a February of this
year what do you think of Martha Stewart
why didn't I I didn't interviewer I just
wrote about the idea of Martha Stewart
and the power she has over large numbers
of you know I mean not over the way she
is she transmits very directly had you
and that is that how you explain her
phenomenon well I think I think I part
of it seems to me that what she's
transmitting isn't isn't what people
think she's transmitting people think
that people are that she has all of
these the people are actually paying
attention to the recipes to the to the
tips about that you know making the
Easter Bunny for your table or the
research done I don't think that's what
people are watching if I think the
people are watching her because she's
successful that she is a that she has
has somehow prevailed in a man's world
right and I think she got out of the
house she made it she build herself when
you read the web that a lot of websites
devoted to her when you read them over
and over again you see the same phrases
she got out of the house she took she
elevated she
I mean it's one of those it doesn't she
fulfills a lot of people's actual
desires yeah
West Hollywood California hello you're
next oh yes hi I really enjoy your work
miss Gideon and I have four years and I
wanted to ask you two a question more
about the present media and if you
happen to think this is a kind of
dangerous time what with the
consolidation of corporations that are
controlling media sources and yet the
voracious need for filler it seems like
in shows whether they're soft news shows
or argue shows that that there's an
increasing slant it seems like on
stories and yet other stories are not
covered at all and that eventually this
could have quite an effect on you know
people's information in this country
these days just wondering about using
awesome I think I think I think it's a
huge concern particularly the the amount
of non information was just bombard
that's every day on the other end
outside the major media and I mean I
don't know something like like salon and
he shot an amazing number of good pieces
and by younger writers are really
looking at stuff and thinking about it
and so housing all it's totally hopeless
you use a computer I do use a computer
yeah I learned to use a computer in 1987
to you know basically is a typewriter
basically because I couldn't get my
typewriter fixed anymore you know
everything it became clear that I had to
move on she have an electric or a manual
I had a on IBM electric yeah um but I
was just using as a typewriter until
last summer when I got a when I finally
I know using God I'm you know the dog
made me so logical I don't use and I
learned to write a whole different way
once once I start
using a computer because it was so
logical I started thinking more
logically I mean it really tells me a
lot
right I started writing a different kind
of piece what happened last summer was I
had to go to windows because das you
couldn't basically pick it that fixed
anymore either and when I went to
Windows I got a high-speed net
connection and and so I do yeah you know
can actually use it
Joyce Carol Oates told us she resented
that she went back from the computer
react to the typewriter because she
found the computer too addictive well I
thought when she originally talked about
it that she found it they were I mean I
remember her saying there were too many
options because you could work so fast
in the computer that says the option she
could she could and I had a certain
sense of that you could that everything
was arbitrary we risked having rather
the sentence done with this word rather
than with that word it was all arbitrary
on the computer because you could change
it so fast but then I got over KB if you
just I don't think she ever worked
through a whole book with on a computer
you work better because of computers I
think it's much better yeah because it's
much faster in the hand you're able to
but the faster you work the longer
you're able to be more sustained an idea
you're able to carry through do you edit
on the computer yeah mmm do you edit a
lot oh yeah and it constantly but what I
do is I print out all the time and can
scratch it up on it and then just in it
and then and then make it up add it
further on the complete I like to see
the printed word we want to I have to
see the printed word yeah
next is Minneapolis good afternoon Joan
I'm current asked about your story Los
Angeles notebook yeah and I read this in
a class on literary nonfiction a few
years back and my interpretation the the
five shorts here
I seem to see similarity between each of
the five shorts you thought we start off
talking about the sin and a winds and
then then you the second one on the sex
for the secretary that are the sex in
the office on the radio and I think to
see common thread through each of the
short and that relating to kind of the
wind and the push and pull of human
communication and and relation when I
when I mentioned this in my course my
professor seemed to think that I was
reaching for that interpretation and
that the stories were not connected that
they were all completely random I wanted
to just get a chance to hear from you
know your thoughts on that well they
weren't they weren't written as
connected pieces however it's something
I mean they were really written as parts
of other of each one of those was a part
of a longer piece and I just pulled them
together but obviously the purpose the
same person wrote them and one person we
pull them together and selected those
those particular pieces and got so I
definitely I had something in my mind
but I never think about what it was what
does it like to hear someone she sounds
fairly young to have said that they have
used your work in class in a classroom
setting
you know startling I mean I mean why
darling darling anymore but but but it
was certainly startling to me when I
first encountered it because you just
never think of your own of your own work
being used in the classroom classrooms
or Thomas Hardy you know do you add is
your work sometimes over interpreting I
think everybody's work is over interpret
by what by which I don't mean those
things aren't there I mean when I was in
college of I was at Berkeley and the the
English and I was in the English
department in the in the English
department at the time I was an
undergraduate was was very wrapped up in
what was called new criticism and new
criticism depended on your basically
over interpreting every
we would do image studies of health and
garden imagery and Henry James's
portrait of a lady stuff like you know
stuff of water imagery you know we do
all that and all that was there but I
don't we didn't to say that Henry James
put it there I mean but what Henry James
has in it has in his mind isn't
accessible to him
he is what he wrote as an expression of
something in his mind that he hasn't
analyzed you see I mean it's I think a
lot most writers don't analyze where the
step down comes from San Francisco
you're next hi I'm to follow up on the
classroom discussion I use your novel
play it as it lays in my classes and I
have to tell you that that the students
enjoy it immensely why do you use it
pardon why do you think well I think
that so often when I use a novel that
that comes from a time they before 1980
I've got to set it up and I've got to
sort of give the student background but
that novel functions so well in and of
itself because I think it speaks to an
experience that everybody has when they
have to decide how to how to play it as
it were mm-hmm and my students respond
to it so immediately I guess that's very
gratifying and I wanted to know if I
could wear some of your characters came
from for that novel Helene is one of our
four favorite ones various reasons and
if you could speak about her bit and
I'll take my answer on the air thank you
Helene was a not based on anybody in
particular um there are lines of
Hollings that says that I sort of picked
up I was I was living in Los Angeles at
the time and a certain line the furs
were things I heard people say in
different contexts
so I think one of them was the line
about the Laszlo was something I heard
that a friend of mine actually said but
she didn't come from anybody in
particular and Mariah came from nobody
in particular exception I had an image
in my mind I'd seen somebody I was in
Las Vegas and I had seen a on actresses
a you know a sort of a young me I mean
not a well-known actress but it was Nate
his name I knew was paged and she was
walking across the casino and in a white
dress with a little halter dress and I
started wondering about you know what
she was doing there I said it and I
never knew but that was the that was the
beginning of Mariah I tell our teacher
and also any other teachers are out
there that that's this is teaching as
part of what why we do what we do here
at c-span there are a variety of ways
you can get involved in RC spend in the
classroom series and you can use any
video tapes we also have certain ways in
which we can give you some lesson plans
we have lesson plans we put together for
programs like this you can contact us
that c-span and we can tell you a little
bit more about RC spend in the classroom
series if you'd like to use programs
like this in your in your classroom next
is Morris County New Jersey hello go
ahead Morris County and I would like to
first of all thank you for having Joan
on your show today I find that this is
one of my favorite things to do on
Sundays is to watch book TV my first
question would be when you were 5 years
old Joan and you were given that tablet
you were writing for yourself you were
writing to express something that was
going on within you at that time and
then later you said that you were
writing because you obviously knew
people were going to read what you were
writing well you you I mean obviously
you're writing to know I mean I knew
somebody was going to read
that story about the I mean my mother
was winner betta which is your first big
audience right what a critic
yeah so you you write to express
something and I mean it's a double sing
but you but but if nobody read it they
would be very difficult to believe that
the expression was worth was worth
bothering with you follow up North
County pardon your follow up yes my
follow up question is basically where is
the most interesting place you've ever
seen a copy of your book or someone
reading your book perhaps on an airplane
or wherever you might be
do you have a story to tell us about
something like that you know I have
almost never seen anybody reading one of
my talks I walk around particularly we
used to go to Hawaii a lot and every
time I was on a beach in Hawaii I would
walk along looking for just too late
what everybody was reading on the beach
right none of them were reading my they
were reading Robert Ludlum they were
read they were they were reading there
reading everybody practically except me
this was how many books which book has
sold the best so far yes
over the years weirdly enough slouching
towards Bethlehem so we'll the most
common figures it sells more every year
of the novel that I mean the novel that
sold the most in terms of at the time of
publication was splashing toward
Bethlehem I think not sake the Book of
Common Prayer book will come for you not
me let me show this one because we
haven't shown this what is the story
about this is a story about a woman well
it's kind of a complicated setup it was
what was one of my it but the basic
character in it is a woman whose
daughter has gone underground and she
ends up in a small
country in Central America mean little
country and she ends up being killed in
a revolution but I thought it was like
one of those five-day revolutions when
it wasn't it was just a change there's a
coup it was not a big and it came out of
that novel came out of a book out of a
trip I had made to Colombia and it had
nothing to do with Colombia but it was
there was a plane to Colombia to Bogota
had stopped in the Panama Airport and I
became very wrapped up in the the idea
of Central America and then I got sick
in Colombia and so I had a lot of time
on my hands I just read do a lot of
reading and focus on on this idea so
with the so that came out of that I've
had a lot of stuff from the 60s in it
too
this is one of your books has been
translated into a foreign language yeah
there are others yeah all of them pretty
much all of them yeah and it is it
exclusively in Spanish orient oh no
scenario most of them have been
translated into Spanish and Portuguese
but um also German also Japanese less
often in France
I've been exactly rarely in France
Tacoma Washington you're next hello oh
yes I would have a couple quarts but
actually I have about a dozen questions
trying to limit it to one I'm curious
about your comment concerning the
reaction of El Salvador I happen to be
instructing in a community college in
many of the things that you'd written
especially that one thing we're in the
anthologies that we used you made the
comment that you didn't think that it
really had much of an impact
and and I'm just to two questions there
why would you say that and also you know
how long did you stay in El Salvador and
what was your own emotional reaction to
the experience of being down there
during all this my eyes I only stayed
was slightly longer than two weeks
my my emotional reaction was really
strong as you can guess from the book
but I really felt as if I was in shock
the whole time I was there
the one I said I did it hadn't any
impact I didn't mean that it wasn't red
I meant that
it didn't have any impact on American
policy um in the in the situation st.
Paul Minnesota
yes it's an honor and a pleasure to be
able to simply say hello to you listed
in listen thank you you're my favorite
writer and when the lady the caller
asked you whether for an example you had
been thinking about writing about
Hillary Clinton you said you had been
thinking about that at all all I could
think of was you as a literary
battleship you're coasting out there
you're out on the water and if you turn
that ship around and those guns are
leveled yet a subject you blow the
subject right out of the water and I'm
also reminded of recently listening to
affect Denison Karen Blixen soon when
she came to the United States many years
ago and at this lecture she said she
wanted to make absolutely certain that
every word every line in out of Africa
was true and she went on to explain why
that meant so much to her when I read
you miss vidiians I perceived every line
to be true well thank you and as most of
us either know or we certainly should
know that's because you have done all
the work like great writers and artists
do before we pick up the book and read
the essay I had the good luck once in
California to happen to get a collection
of your essays the one containing the
Santa Ana winds and it became California
to me your essay epitomize personified
totally communicated California to me
and you've done the same in so many
other ways and I sometimes we are
self-conscious and feel inferior
Americans in in a literary sense in a
critical sense but just when we get
discouraged we pick up something by Joan
Didion's one of the reviews and the New
York reviewer The New Yorker magazine
and it's like Joe DiMaggio stepping up
to the plate and I just want to thank
you a thousand times my daughter
standing here she said ask her how she
stays sane in this crazy world we live
in you have the answer about I don't
have the answer but thank you for
calling speaking of the New York Review
of Books this is a recent one actually
was November of last year in which he
wrote about Dutch yes hmm did you like
the book I did not like the book no I
object to the literary device an idea
that wasn't my objection to it I just
thought but it didn't get very close to
anything does this did Dutch change it
all the way we think about biography I
don't think it changed anything does it
change the way you think about biography
I mean when I kept reading these things
with the device being so either so
shocking or so revolutionary the device
didn't work I mean it had the device
worked it would have uh it would have
been fine but it but it but it didn't
work it was cooking and I was clumsily
handled you got to really know how to do
those things which I don't think he did
and they didn't study so that was the
problem with it when you sit down to
read a book well have you read the book
before you find out that you're going to
review it or no I went and the book for
review so I read it and then I read the
Roosevelt book and then I read the
Roosevelt book again and then I this is
his previous book about Theodore
Roosevelt and you weren't all that
excited about that money I wasn't no and
so and I read it a second time because I
thought maybe I just been skimming and
missing something you know there must be
more here than meets the eye but there
was going back to 1996 New York Review
of Books you reviewed a holster the
whole series of books not everyone but
five of them that Bob Woodward has
written and you come up with this these
are books in which measurable cerebral
activity is virtually absent ouch hmm
you know that was not a do you just not
like what Bob Woodward writes I did I I
did there again is one of those cases
when you read something and you think
there must be more here than meets the
eye and probably I'm not getting it cuz
I don't know really very much about the
subject and I wasn't until I started
reading books if it was where I did know
quite a bit about the subjects that I
saw there was really not that he hadn't
really in a lot of cases thought things
through did you hear from mr. Woodward
after this all no do you ever hear from
people you write about no no nor would I
I mean I get terrible reviews to and I
wouldn't I I mean I never get in touch
with the reviewer no which is your worst
reviewing memory though I all I have
I've had so many I can't he I write him
I mean if I dwell if I were to dwell on
them it would it would make me furious
all the time and keep me awake at night
and so I decided to show them off but I
do read them Los Angeles you're next
um I have a couple of things that I'd
like to ask you about I guess are
related things growing up in Northern
California near Sacramento I would say
you're one of a handful of writers who
write about that part of the country
when I left California I lived in Hawaii
for a while I read democracy before I
went to read democracy what I was there
and there was a way in which you nailed
Hawaii the people and the place that was
really unique you got the insight
earnest outside earnest as well as the
physical place and so I guess I'm
wondering at this point what places are
interesting you at this are you looking
outward are you looking at other are you
engaging with other parts of the world
well I am I want to know what I wanted
I've written a couple of pieces of a
long pieces about California I mean
they're good Exodus they were kind of
about the idea of can they be what they
were getting to is to be about with the
idea of California and so I want to do a
third piece if I want is not a third
piece but I want to I want to take those
pieces and take them another step you
know and you know maybe make it into a
longer thing which would end up being a
book democracy was written in 1984
democracy was written in 1984 it took me
forever to write it because I wasn't
using a computer and it was a very
complicated book and I would just kept
getting up against I kept getting to
page 89 and then I would get discouraged
and not know where to go and so I would
I was so I mean it took me so long I
never usually a book as you get towards
the end and novels it will take off and
you'll you'll be working very fast and
you will know that sooner or later is
like I suppose like being pregnant
sooner or later you're going to have
this baby a sooner or later this
business thing is going to happen you're
going to be finished you can see it
coming your work toward it
I never felt that with with democracy is
simply Burma Graham green once wrote
about a book of his that didn't take off
because it's a physical thing is a
resistant book right up till the very
end and this one was so resistant that
when I finished it I didn't think of it
as finishing it I thought of it as a
jumping ship or abandoning it you know I
just finished I just I just want to be
rid of it I did the math right on your
novels they came out what 63 70 70 784
almost Excel the LAT of the house when
we note well longer yeah I think what
happened there is if my whole schedule
got thrown off because we moved from
California to New York which put me
about two years behind took me that long
to find out where I'd put things
Washington DC you next miss Diddy and I
was wondering who some of the major
influences have been both in teaching
you how to be a superb journalist and
also in writing fiction in your own
reading would you be able to point to
certain writers that have either gained
your respect or in some way have helped
you to develop your own skills I think
that um I mean I I read so much fiction
I mean you know was when I was in school
and later that would be hard and hard to
name and ticketed but the people I still
read I never start a novel without
reading Joseph Conrad's victory I never
start a novel without reading and I
carry it with me and I carry the Ford
Madox force the good soldier with me
as far as nonfiction goes Edmund Wilson
did great reporting it's always a
difficult there's a collection of is
reporting called the American earthquake
which is just it's just the kind of
thing you want to do it just goes and
looks at stuff and then writes about it
and Elizabeth Hardwick did it did really
good reporting I'm Mary McCarthy did
good reporting
I mean those are the people I was
reading you know when I was starting out
to do this what are you reading right
now
why did Frankie [ __ ] girls book which
is fantastic I think on it
this is the new one on the elegant in
the way out there's a Reagan way out
there and in the blue these are Wars
yeah it's the line since the line from
death row sales and it's really good
next is other in Washington if I want to
adjourn about the book she wrote El
Salvador Salvador who who what was she
right now about him Salvador after she
wrote her first book I wouldn't write
anything about El Salvador now because I
haven't been there I mean really that
the book Harbor I was really about
American involvement there it wasn't
about El Salvador it was called Salvador
but it was about it was about our
efforts there whatever that was at that
moment Boston hello John how are you
hello
I think you'd comment if you will on a
quote from Philip Roth in the current
issue of New Yorker magazine a profile
of his and says by readers he said he
means people who read serious book
seriously and consistently
the evidence is everywhere the littered
the literary area airy era has come to
an end he said the evidence is the
culture the evidence is the society the
evidence is the screen the progression
from movie screen to the television
screen to the computer I jump ahead here
literature takes a habit of mind that
has disappeared it requires silence some
form of isolation and sustain this
sustained
tration in the presence of an animatic
thing would you comment on his view of
this well what I found I thought that
was a I mean I thought a very
encouraging profile this is a profile of
by David Remnick of the Philip Roth and
I found it really wonderful because I
mean because of inspiring because he was
still doing it he was he was still
working it's believing that he was still
working I think everybody feel to some
extent that there has been a a decrease
in the general ability to read some
kinds of material I don't think people
understood I don't think large numbers
of people understand how to read fiction
anymore they I think the general reader
of fiction tends to read it at to take
the characters at face value I mean the
knowledge that that I narrate or in a
novel might be lying to you for example
is now it seems to have passed from look
that's that that which was taken for
granted at the time we all learn to read
novels I don't think it's taken for
granted so much anymore it
however those people who still who still
do know how to read really read so it's
good it's a it's not a I don't think the
lost cause is it is that there a way to
learn how to read as you are describing
it if you were never taught that well I
don't know I mean I think if you read if
you start reading through this
through the stories trying to analyze
how novel
you know how novels actually work as
opposed to trying to figure out how to
reflect the life of the author which
they don't
I mean don't in a in a faithful way we
went when I said that I thought that I
always read victory one of the points I
mean one of the things that continually
just dazzles me about victory is that
this is a two story you aren't even
hearing this story at first hand you're
hearing at you or at second hand you're
hearing a story the story is being told
to you by somebody who heard it from
somebody who heard it from somebody else
and yet you become very and despite that
that that distancing from the story
you become very engrossed with this
story of actual heist and his tropical
belt coal company but you're seeing it
from a distance which is very like the
distance in real life what I mean is
he's not he's not made totally clear to
you you're you're you're looking from
over here which is I mean I don't pay it
so just look but people don't actually
get as excited a lot of people to
actually get as excited about this as I
do next is Bend org and you're on with
Joan Didion hi my question is related to
a couple comments you made you just
mentioned Francis Fitzgerald's book and
your book Salvador and going back to neo
seems bright shining light it seems like
someone that grew up as a baby boomer it
seems like our entire value system is a
failed by the facts in other words what
can we believe in what what alternative
is there but deep cynicism and I'm sort
of wondering how that how that plays
against your everyday life and how do
you how do you get along it seems very
difficult to do well I grew up actually
before the baby boom and grew up with
with it with with existential and with
the existentialism had just been
introduced okay if you have really
existential philosophy
it's somehow it's easier to hold of
these you don't get cynical you just
kind of hold things that a you don't
know it's a slightly different turn of
mind I find my a cynicism is beyond me I
don't actually get cynical I mean it's
it's not in my vocabulary
Sandy Hook Connecticut I thanks for
taking my call I really have never read
anything by you Joan but it's
interesting to hear you talk I spent a
lot of time in from the late 70s to the
late 80s in the Middle East and one of
the most intriguing parts of the world
to specifically be up in Pakistan
Afghanistan and I really among your
contemporaries as in authors and
thinkers I am always looking for some
author to really write about the subject
of that portion of the Middle East to
include what really really went down
there if you really take a look at the
development of the nukes and Kashmir
problem and Allah I really like I say
I've been there
spent some time there and if you take a
look at books like the spike here you've
read that about disinformation and
things like that that's really that's a
whole interesting area and it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't covered it
wasn't available it was for one thing
American borders tend to go places that
are nearby and where they know the
language this was this was in all I
think it was very hard I think that
situation for a reporter would have been
needed hard to penetrate however it did
go it means it's a blank spot in our on
our map at this am are historical now
San Leandro California I thanks Connie
for book TV
and a stadion I was wondering you
mentioned about your books being
translated into different languages and
I was wondering I believe you said
something about not being translated so
much in France mm-hmm and it seemed to
me you have kind of a French kind of
conciseness and clarity about your
writing and I was wondering it seemed
kind of curious that you aren't being
published so much in France as maybe in
some other countries I wanted he had
some thoughts on that I don't have any
any insight into that is it's one is
this one of those those are those little
cultural mysteries of I love rounds and
I would love to publish more there who
makes that decision and D are you
involved at all you're not involved at
all it's made by the foreign publishers
so even if you wanted to be you couldn't
go and no know that I always all done
through your agent in its and it
submitted and then they do something or
they don't do something who's your agent
líneas but at GenCon there's but is
money yeah and what does she she she
what did she do for you what's the role
of an agent will see she she sells
things but that's basically what they do
I mean she she's she's a friend as well
as an agent I mean she was Jaws agent
for long before she was mine and we were
quite close friends your husband John
yes the COO it's been he's been
mentioned several times here we have
already talked about yeah yes my husband
is a writer too John Gregory does it was
so basically you complain to your agent
you she's who you complain to she she's
who you
say I want more money she's who you say
get me out of this back to your husband
he has written written novels written
man feel and you've written screenplays
together we have you know what's that
process like it's a job it's sort of fun
I mean we've been doing it the other
voice basically it's always supported
ourselves for a long time so it's I mean
it's been good to us and it's very fun
to do it as a technical problem or
something like writing because you're
making something that somebody else is
this answer is going to write the
director but but you can so it's your
main move you make suggestions you know
you're making so I think it's kind of
fun how long have you been married we
were married in January of 1964 Joan
Didion's our guest for in-depth this
month we're going to take two more calls
then we're going to take just a short
break and we'll be back with the rest of
our program and continue taking calls
next call is from Clarendon Hills
Illinois yes miss Didion very quickly i
just i teach writing classes at DePaul
University and I I'm interested at first
of all and whether or not your facility
with language the fest facility with
which you're right whether this is
something that comes to you very easily
or whether you struggle with words
individually on the page as you as you
write and then the other thing is have
there been any great teachers in your
background and the other final question
has to do with the fact that we teach
persona in writing and you've commented
about that you are obviously a lot
larger persona much more forceful than
then sometimes your your person in
person you would appear to be and I find
this a very effective thing I'd like to
use this tape as a matter of fact so any
comments about that great teachers and
facility with language I don't have any
facility with language I mean I you know
I use the Saurus
I have to I I walk around the house
trying to think what the worry is of at
least toward the beginning of something
but it's also it's in the right kind of
thing then as you get deeper into it
into a piece or a book whatever you're
doing the language becomes a little more
fluent it's almost like learning a new
language every time as far as teachers
go actually I had a great editor at
Vogue who was a who taught me to do
things over we did a lot basically I was
writing captions for but they were very
closely they had to be a certain number
of characters we counted characters not
words of they had to be a block of text
exactly 30 lines long and each line had
to have 64 characters say that's a
different kind of runs very demanding
and she would say she was I can remember
she would have this big aquamarine ring
she she'd get violently crossing Xing
out things muttering action verbs action
verbs she was a great teacher I mean in
closer names
Ellen tell me she was the future editor
of Vogue and everybody lasted with her
basically learned to write everything uh
but that time you had done through high
school you're coming a college and yeah
buddy there oh well I had really you
know there were people who were
influenced me a lot at Berkeley but God
knows they were they were famous for
less so in high school I didn't actually
like high school I mean it was a it was
a very tedious time on my life I think
they were bored yes I was bored and
didn't really like it San Francisco oh
yeah I guess what got me interested in
your work with a piece that you did
about the spur Posse and I'd like to ask
you about California I love the passion
that you show when you write about the
Hoover Dam and about water and I'm
wondering if that's going to be part of
this third well half that you make it
California thanks I'll take my answer
off the end the piece of the piece that
you mentioned this for a policy piece
which is only nominally about this for a
policy it was actually about the end of
the defense in deterring about the crash
of the defense industry in California
was the you know I mentioned two I'd
done two pieces and that one that piece
of the first one I did it for The New
Yorker it was quite a long piece but it
but it raised more questions with me
that I mean I still had a lot of
unanswered questions when I finished it
and then I did a piece for the New York
we do which took listen questions a
little further now I want yeah so now I
want to just take them a little further
still in the holy water the one that the
essay that is in the White Album yeah a
visit to that was just a visit to the
water control place in Sacramento now
who would think that Joan Didion would
go into the water control place I mean
you did something you just wanted to go
I was dying to visit it yes I mean I
can't really drive by a dam or a they
put out wanting to see how it works um
something you've always been interested
in yeah oh yes mm-hmm there we go it was
it but when I was at Berkeley this is
one of the things that impressed me most
I never got into this place they had and
I passed it every day was a big shed off
Bancroft Avenue and it was a inside
there was a hydraulic model of San
Francisco Bay which they flushed a tide
through
whenever they wanted I was so dying to
go in and spend time with that model
ride and work I never could get in Joan
Didion is our guest for in-depth this
month we're going to take a very short
break and be back with more of your
phone calls and a look at more of her
work 48 hours of nonfiction books on TV
you're watching book TV on c-span two
more of our in-depth interview with Joan
Didion in just a moment then later this
afternoon Francis Fukuyama talks about
his book the great disruption human
nature and the reconstitution of social
order from the campus of Claremont
McKenna College in California tonight on
book TV lucas codis cusses the politics
of the Supreme Court under Chief Justice
Earl Warren
although Malcolm Gladwell talks about
the tipping point his new book exploring
why certain ideas take hold in society
and others do not and biography on book
TV looks at the generalship of robert e
lee for the panel of levi ographers
[Music]
what inspired two stockbrokers to
establish the Gilder Lehrman Institute
of American history and Finance the
annual $50,000
Lincoln Book Prize next Sunday at noon
here on book TV Louis Lehrman and
Richard Gilder talk about their
collection of 39,000 original documents
of history from America's discovery
through the Civil War and reconstruction
at the Morgan Library in New York City
and immediately following this year's
Lincoln prize Award winners with John
Hope Franklin and Allen galvo the Gilder
Lehrman Institute of American history
and the Lincoln prize Award winners all
here on book TV next Sunday starting at
noon Eastern 9 a.m. Pacific 48 hours of
nonfiction books all weekend on TV book
TV on c-span 2 or complete program
schedule simply go to book tv.org Jona
Sunday May 21st for live coverage of the
New York Times Washington literary lunch
we'll hear from Helen Thomas a United
Press International correspondent who's
covered eight presidents also natalie
angie r author of woman and intimate
geography and Stephen Holmes who wrote a
biography of the late Commerce Secretary
Ron Brown the New York Times Washington
literary lunch
Sunday May 21st beginning at 1:00 p.m.
Eastern our web site book tv.org brings
you a look at some of this week's
best-selling books
click on bestseller lists and you'll
find a sampling of nonfiction
bestsellers from across the country
here's a look at one of this week's
featured lists a top 10 best-selling
non-fiction books according to the New
York Times number one this week mich
albums Tuesdays with Maurey it's
followed by The Rock says an
autobiography bought a professional
wrestler known as the rock in the
millionaire mind at number 3 Thomas
Stanley poses questions designed to
assess the readers money-making
potential then former Reagan
speechwriter Peggy Noonan's new books
the case against Hillary Clinton
comes in at number four detective Steve
Thomas discusses his involvement with
the investigation into the murder of
six-year-old JonBenet Ramsey in JonBenet
written with Don Davis Sidney Poitier
writes about his life and career and the
measure of a man at number six this week
it's followed by fair ball a fans case
for baseball by sportscaster Bob Costas
tis the follow-up memoir by Angela's
Ashes author Frank McCourt comes in at
number 8 this week
Cybil Shepherds new autobiography civil
disobedience is knife and Dave Eggers
memoir a heartbreaking work of
staggering genius rounds out the list at
number 10 for book reviews and more
bestseller lists visit the New York
Times website and click on books in a
moment we'll return to our live in-depth
program with author Joan Didion tonight
on our companion Network c-span David
wise
talks about Cassidy's run the secret spy
war over nerve gas Joe Cassidy was a
very ordinary American from a
blue-collar background in Erie
Pennsylvania he dropped out of high
school joined the army and when the FBI
recruited him for the spy operation he
suddenly found himself a secret weapon
in the Cold War without any training and
what was that well his job was to pass
what turned out to be 45,000 pages of
secret documents to the Russians all
under the control of the FBI Joe Cassady
pretended to be a traitor for 21 years
there is and he pretended to be in all
the chains if you will for 21 years it
was a remarkable bit of acting and the
Russians believed it booknotes tonight
at 8 o'clock Eastern and Pacific on our
companion network seized an in-depth
book TVs live series looking at the work
of prolific authors resumes in September
meanwhile this summer will repeat three
earlier in-depth interviews
on June 4th historian John Lucas July
2nd Richard Rhodes and August 6th
William F Buckley in-depth the first
Sunday of every month here on book TV we
are back with our in-depth series with
Joan Didion Joan Didion I want to take
us to watching towards Bethlehem again
and your essay on keeping a notebook any
time we tell our viewers you can go
ahead and call in on the phone on the
phone numbers you'll see at the bottom
of your screen we'll continue taking
your calls you write it but one of the
reasons that you think people should
keep notebooks is to remember who they
were and you wrote I think we are well
advised to keep on nodding terms with
the people we used to be whether we find
them attractive company or not otherwise
they turn up unannounced and surprise us
come hammering on the minds door at 4:00
a.m. of a bad night and demand to know
who deserted them who betrayed them who
is going to make amends we forget all
too soon the things we thought we could
never forget we forget the loves and the
betrayals alike forget what we whispered
and what we screamed forget who we were
you know will we do
what's your notebook like um my notebook
right now is a box and it's been for
years a box a box it's like an archive
box you know a file box and I just throw
throw notes into it in there got to be
something too constricting about just
carrying a notebook around and writing
things down because the first like I
couldn't read my writing anymore I mean
it was just so now I just type notes
when I think of one and throw them in
the box and then do they ever become
part of an essay or part of a novel yeah
usually I go through the box when I'm
working on a novel several times and
stuff something walk jog clippings go in
there to all kinds of stuff goes in
there and sometimes I mean sometimes
that a novel you you make yourself use
all all of all the threads you're thrown
into the box in one way or another I
mean it's just
it's you're making something out of
nothing anyway so you might as well give
yourself some parameters you get in
somehow get it and get in getting a
nuclear explosion you know if as one of
the clippings you wrote it in early in a
part of this essay that in your early
days of keeping a notebook many times
what you wrote in your daily notations
where it wasn't even true that's right
it was just it was it was it was what I
remembered I mean it wasn't it was it's
something it had something to do with
the emotional meaning of it I mean it
just wasn't keeping no notebook isn't
like know what you make four pieces or
during an interview where you try to you
certainly try to put down only what's
through that this is a different kind of
note and this is I don't even it's a
kind of thing that happens in your own
life when you don't even know what's
true and not true anymore
I mean um yes you could figure it out
but I mean it doesn't make any
difference because you you're so wrapped
into the into one version of it or
another
Crichton Nebraska you're next up yes I
just like to tell Joan Didion that I was
in a literary journalism class at U n Oh
a few years back and dr. Warren Frankie
used Salvador and I remember the excerpt
leading into that excerpt where you it
just a town there or the area you've
such a purse and immediately you Zurich
people arming rifles and pistols what
another is the hammer is being engaged
into the firing chambers and you cept
very vividly set I can't describe how
you set stage in that book for the
tension that you didn't even want to
turn around in the street because some
might take a shot at you so what advice
you give to a person who would want to
capture to get this type of immersion in
the first place and then capture the
atmosphere of an area
do you write color on me do you write I
try to and I got another question - real
quickly I was wondering in fact if Jones
are a nonfiction creative nonfiction
illiterates journalism type of a novel
about our current environmental problems
in the rural areas would sell at all
whether it be a market I'll be more
specific will be set here in northeast
Nebraska by a series of factory hog
farms with 14,000 hogs per vocation
divert decontaminate pollutant stink up
the area for the few remaining rural
residents that are stuck in the area and
lowest property values form and the
quality of life we're back east readers
and West Coast readers be interested in
reading about the plight of rural
Americans stuck in this situation also
thanks thanks right I think you asked I
think I think I think people can be made
to be interested in anything if you if
you find a way to tell it to them at the
task is in finding the way to tell it to
them and in in in making it come alive
for them and I mean that's that's the
job there as far as the other the other
part the first part of the question it
seems mean anybody can train themselves
to just to notice what's going on I mean
obviously you're going to notice if you
think you're going to be shot up well so
you just write it down okay so you don't
you don't keep it a secret
san francisco hi my name is Bill and I
just want to say that it's a real
pleasure to be able to say hello to miss
Diddy and I was and I wanted to thank
you for earlier novels like plate as it
lays and run River and journalistic
endeavors like The White Album my
question was in terms of this
conversational portrait that you did of
Nancy Reagan in that original
oh yeah pretty Nancy Reagan er right
gosh do you do you think people change
what that's one question I guess I'm I
guess my question to you is has your
sense of the woman changed since that
writing anything in her public life that
would have suggested more of a depth
than was may be rendered in that piece I
am and I actually reviewed her
autobiography for the New York Review
and I found it to be a pretty consistent
cannot be inconsistent with with with
with the the piece I had done obviously
she's going through it through a
terrible time now and she's doing it
gracefully which is I think everybody
feel for at this moment is it fair to
say that when you wrote about the Reagan
the piece I had done obviously she's
going through it to a terrible time now
and she's doing it gracefully which is I
think everybody feels for at this moment
is it fair to say that when you wrote
about the Reagan's when they were in the
White House part of your essay you
actually wrote through the eyes of
speechwriter Peggy Noonan that's right
yeah that was that was a I can't even
remember that maybe that was a different
piece wasn't it wasn't the same piece
there's a piece of the piece I'm talking
about was a review of my turn maybe I
did pay newton's book at the same time
why did you choose Peggy notice on the
book was out there uh I wanted to
probably I had been probably if I had to
reconstruct it I would think probably
that Bob Stover today asked me to review
Nancy Reagan's book and
and I needed something more some other
way to coming at it I used another book
there too okay I used them a book about
Hollywood a book of photographs of
Hollywood a brilliant book of
photographs by Jean Howard the one in
which you used a lot of a lot of the
work a Peggy Noonan I think was in the
realm of Fisher King that for after
Henry that was yeah in after Henry yep I
think that's it New York City you're
next hello go ahead in New York hi Here
I am I'd like to know if you had a
student or somebody who was a disciple
if you work somebody who's read all of
your work and you were able to suggest
the next focus of their attention if you
would say this is the next important
area that a writer with the heightened
sort of literary nonfiction sensibility
would direct his attention where would
you direct them Columbia why well we're
running a war there is basically have
you written anything yourself no no I
haven't I mean I haven't been down next
call is from Los Angeles high forehead
Los Angeles thank you sir I have two
questions one listening to you I can't
help thinking of the essay you wrote I
don't know maybe seven or eight years
ago I can't member which book it was in
about actually doing book tours and I
remember sort of basically about how not
very comfortable it is waking up in
Dallas or something in a green room I
was having done that myself I know how
horrible it is that so are you really
like what's your what's the quality of
the experience as you do this right now
for you and the other question is did
you I'm sure you either read or somebody
probably told you about the essay I
don't know 15 years ago that Barbara
Harris barbecue Dean Harrison Road sort
of trying to demolish you I've always
wondered what you thought of it this is
a piece that began the first line of it
was what was something along the lines
of or maybe this is it exactly am I
expected to admire a woman who had
burden her daughter with the name Quinto
no rude
well after that we'll go from there
where do you go I mean I knew I wasn't
going to get a break if my daughter's
name was fair game in the first line so
that was I mean I it was it I was you
know I guess there were points in their
fee time in fact I had had I admire
Barbara's doing Harris and she wrote a
fantastic book about growing up a
Jehovah's Witness it's so interesting
and so so I was sorry she felt so
strongly about me but it was a but you
couldn't get too worked up about it
since it was kind of over the top
experience of the author tour
well the actually talking in public so I
would this experience or doing it and
actually doing it is never as hard as as
actually getting there to do it you know
I mean the kind of waiting to do it
doing it you know logistics of doing it
flew out here from the west coast to do
this show ferns know I came from New
York oh you came from yeah mm-hmm so
actually doing that you put your mind
you kind of engage your mind in a
different Drive and do it but uh it's
very it's rather hard for me actually
because I'm quite inarticulate South
Yarmouth Massachusetts hi
just a comment and then a quick question
Joan Didion this is such an honor to say
hello to you because I think you're
absolutely the greatest author in the
English language I marvel at your work
and you have a surprise that you have
such trouble with words you said it what
didn't wouldn't be like yeah as you are
just absolutely wonderful of word was
thank you about it and the other thing
is I wanted you to know if you could
comment on Truman Capote's writing if
you are like just writing it all because
he's another author that I would like to
what to my odds and I love Breakfast at
Tiffany's I try we know it was it was it
was a it was a perfect of what it was
you know I really did like it a lot New
York City yes I am familiar with much of
a city ins work and I would like to know
based on that body how she feels about
the difficulty if she thinks there is
any difficulty in shifting from
nonfiction to fiction and then back
again and what role that is like and how
she feels the material of her life and
her reporting feeds into both thank you
there is a certain the different term
with the obviously it's a different the
experience of writing fiction is
radically different from the experience
of writing nonfiction nonfiction you
gotta got a bunch of stuff you do the
research first you've got it there and
now it's a matter of shaping it up
getting it it's like sculpting you know
it's like making something out of
granite fiction there's a grid level as
you wake up every single morning with
the idea that it's not worth doing it
and you're going to have to make up
something out of nothing that day once
again and until until you reach that
point I mentioned before when it takes
off and and for better or for worse
you're going to finish the novel it's a
it's a really it's a big question every
day whether it but it was this is why
you're doing this it takes till about
5:00 in the afternoon in fact I go to
work in the morning about you know about
10:00 10:30
it's not until about 5:00 in the
afternoon that I actually start hitting
a rhythm where I get a page done and
look the best time then once you hit
that rhythm you can work maybe for
another two or three hours but until you
get hungry
to here but it takes all day to just
overcome fear up where do you write
I don't know office in our apartment so
you never leave your apartment she's not
I stay home do you ever go anyplace else
in right besides that office no I've
never written any place except home when
once when we got a small house week and
a new baby we've rented an office it
didn't work out it was just something
but didn't work about going to an office
what does the office look like what what
do you surround yourself with well it's
an extra bedroom and it's got without a
bed and it's got got a bunch of piles of
books and piles of papers and it's not
very orderly and it's got some you know
it's got a chair where I can go sit and
do needlepoint if I get stuck and it's
got a bunch of stuff to stuff you know
how does an HR go to the needlepoint you
can serve mindless you can think you can
sit there and and actually think and yet
you're if you do it at a moment when you
think you can't think when you can't
think of what it you should sort of
panicking right you start doing
needlepoint and you think you're doing
you can trick yourself into thinking I'm
doing something useful I'm working on
this rug right and but it's so mindless
that you can actually find yourself you
can sort of sneak into thinking about
something else
San Francisco I yes a question for the
host first will it be possible to
acquire other not being a teacher a copy
of this program absolutely we have a
regular way in which viewers that they
want a copy of the program can purchase
a copy it's a fairly nominal fee you can
call one 800 CC 8 and that's not only
for this program for it but for any
program that you see on so you spend one
800 seats Bend 98 thank you event for
miss Didion being from the Central
Valley myself I feel a certain affinity
and pride frankly and in your work I'm
wondering you talked about Columbia if
you've worked and salvaged
or have you done anything are you
considering doing anything on looking at
Mexico specifically the culture rather
than the politics I know I haven't I
haven't I haven't ever worked in Mexico
see I don't know why I have I just
haven't maybe because it was so
extensively written about that I felt
that I couldn't contribute as much as
anybody else could I I don't know I just
hasn't hasn't hasn't presented itself to
me Ripley West Virginia yes many years
ago I read it and say you did on
migraine headaches and although I loved
all your work that one has seemed to me
to be one of the best things I've ever
read on migraines I'm coming off of one
right now and I was just wondering if
you still get migraines or do you have
people come up to you and say boy your
essay was really great about migraine it
the Zen part of it made so much sense
you know I got more at the time that
piece came out I got more mail on it and
I ever gotten another piece in my entire
life
you wrote it in 1968 yeah this one
called in bed and it's you can find it
in the White Album yeah but I still get
my rain not to the extent that I use
something I've learned how to control
them a little better there was a
terrific book I don't know if you've
read it by Oliver Sacks a neurologist
who wrote a book called migraine it was
originally published by the University
of California Press and I think recently
it's been a few years ago was
republished with a new introduction in a
in paper you know trade paperback I
think you'll find it fascinating because
it talks about the experience in a real
in a really familiar way you're talking
here and correct me if I'm wrong but if
I recall of the idea of accepting we've
never accepting the migraine ended up
also of concentrating on the pain yeah
you concentrate on the fan you
you live with it it it's a learning to
live with problem
Rocky Mountain North Carolina hi my name
is Esther and Miss Didion I first read
your essay on self-respect as a junior
in high school and ever since that time
I've always come back to it and found
some new insiders a new inspiration and
I was wondering looking back 40 years
since you had written it if if your idea
of what it takes to have self-respect
has evolved and also I was curious about
what point in your life you were able to
write on that subject actually the point
in my life when I was I was working for
Vogue and this was a piece that had been
assigned to someone else who hadn't
delivered it and it was already on the
cover the cover said on self-respect and
so so I was asked to write a piece about
self-respect and and it was and I would
be able to sign up right which was most
of my stuff in vote wasn't signed at
that time so I did it and so I started
you know thinking about it and it was
you know wrote what was in my mind
obviously uh it was I I do remember one
thing about writing out which was does
it had to be done so rapidly I did the
first part of it the part that was in
the in a form you know magazines are
arranged in forms and it was some forms
close earlier than other forms so the
part of it that was in the well of the
book I wrote first and close that and
then in a week later I wrote the ending
because that wasn't closing until weeks
later so it was it was it totally under
the gun kind of kind of thing but it but
it had but it you know but it was
something I've I felt heavy changed
about yeah of course you change your
audios I don't I don't know exactly how
about but but but it would hardly be
worth living if our ideals in the end of
all how physical this Menlo Park
California
Lila Parker then go ahead hello I've
never called him to c-span before I
better turn off the radio play new
television sorry um hi Joan I was at
Berkeley with you oh I did you didn't
you take a class for Mark Shore I did
yeah it was in that same class Chrissy
yeah you weren't Joan Didion yes and I
wasn't myself yet we heard the same you
know Marsh court-martial was he was he
taught a very small class in fiction
writing and it was it was it was it was
considered a very special class to get
into and yes and I have gone on to be a
professional writer I had four
non-fiction books and what I one of the
reasons I called was and I identified so
strongly with what you were saying about
how much more difficult fiction is I
mean I can interview anybody and write
it up I can write on an assignment but
fiction which I love doing but it is
tough isn't it yes it is color until it
can you might tell us your name and what
you've written my name is Doris Butler
I'm I've written books on history of the
Santa Clara Valley
women in politics a woman's guide to San
Francisco I live in the Bay Area we
don't and I had the pleasure of editing
the book with Wally Stagner which was a
great experience anyway I've just
recently completed my first novel and
gotten lots of comment one was from
Jonathan grassy which I was thrilled
that he wanted to see it elver plotted
he said much cross and the name of it
all the roads to Rome it isn't published
yet who is publishing it well it's not
yet ah the rounds I'll making the rounds
then that she's in that she says she's
in the scary part yeah you don't have to
make the rounds anymore
well everybody feels they do
they do Suez you know I was I got so
scared in that class that I that I
couldn't speak I didn't speak for the
entire class and why I just felt too shy
you know and to inadequate indicate it
was just I mean it was it was my food I
was a little shy and and this was so
special or class but I feel totally
incapable but their time during your
during your writing and during your
career that you would get you got more
confidence and able to accept people
like this calling calling in and saying
I new UN or people who are asking for
advice on their writing well it's a very
gradual you know there's a very grand
also at a certain point in your life you
decide you're not going to be shy
anymore I mean I remember doing it when
I was about 24 25 simply forcing myself
to go into some kind of situation that I
was too shy to do right because because
it wasn't you know it's alright for
little girls to be shy but it's not too
cute and people went groan remind like
Sandra Virginia you're next I'm miss
Diddy and I'm a graduate student at
Berkeley but I'm not here visiting my
parents now Avandia I'm really happy to
see you on TV today I'm a fan of Yura
say goodbye to all that about leaving
New York kinda I was I was a little
surprised to hear you say I think that
you said that you'd move back to me you
moved back from New York in 1988 yes I
thought if you could say a little bit
about why you moved back and what it's
like to return and after having a
statement such as made such an eloquent
farewell to New York what's it like to
be back there well it's I mean it's
totally different cuz I'm at a different
moment in my life it's totally different
in some ways it's I mean it all looks
the same more or less the same but but
but it's but it's but it feels different
because I am it at a different point
my life and and also it was now it's I
had been when we lived in Los Angeles I
spent a lot of time in New York
naturally I mean you come in to do
business or something and and be there
for a period of a week or two weeks and
so this is sort of like an extension as
I grew used to being in New York in a
different way and I had been when I
lived there just out of school and this
is like an extension of those visits
from California the long visit from
California Seattle Washington
good afternoon no I I was in college a
long time ago about 1213 years ago
remember reading an article it was an
essay and one of our books that you had
done in the mid-60s about Nancy Reagan I
think was called pretty Nancy right at
the time it struck me as rather
clairvoyant that was in the 60s and most
of America got to know Reagan's in the
80s I'm wondering when you wrote that
article what was your intent and
secondly what has been the fallout oh
here's from that and have your opinions
changed of miss Reagan over the years
the um it wasn't really clear what
because he because Ronald Reagan was at
the time Governor of California and he
was being talked about for a forum or
Politico for higher office and so they
were very much a worth a this was
written it I think as a column for one
or another magazine sort of fairly short
piece so it was a fairly obvious idea to
do to do at the time Austin Texas hello
miss Didion son I wanted to talk to you
I am just finishing up my final
semesters of college and last semester I
was lucky enough to be introduced to
your work in slouching towards Bethlehem
and there is an essay in there entitled
on keeping a notebook if I have it
correctly mm-hmm and I know I heard you
earlier say that you you write within
your home and you don't tend to write
anywhere else but I'm wondering do you
still have that propensity because when
I read that for myself
it resonated completely because I've
always had this feeling that I have to
have this paper somewhere in case
something strikes me so that I can write
write it down write something down and
I'm wondering if you still have that
that needs yourself
I carry cards in my bag you know sort of
white car white index cards that I can
write something down if I if it occurs
to me Los Angeles hi miss Gideon when
our daughters graduated from Westlake
you spoke at their baccalaureate those
are my daughter's baccalaureate ooh yes
IDOT our daughter yes what I said ours
in mind and that speech has resonated in
my mind and throughout my life since
then it became very true for Lisa she
became a lawyer you talked about the
lawyer you know not having the office
with the potted palm in the horner but
going down to Lincoln Heights and 2:00
a.m. in the morning and it was funny
because our fathers got in the car
afterwards I said well if she becomes a
lawyer she's not getting up at 2:00 a.m.
to go to Lincoln Heights
laughs you know what years later there's
yes but at any rate I wanted a copy of
that if it's at all possible
it is write to me I think they're going
to give up an address yeah we do have in
care of kaname yeah mmm we'll put that
up on the screen color and it is a an
address that you can write in care of
Knopf publishing and then I'll and I'll
send it to you it was excellent clothing
and thank you again thank you Iowa City
Iowa you're next hi Joan I am graduating
from the Iowa Writers Workshop this
spring and I'm just wondering what what
you think of workshops writing workshops
in general and graduate writing degrees
well I don't know I mean anyway you can
learn to write as anything that forces
you to write is I don't think anybody
can teach you to write except doing it
and if and if you get into a program
that forces you to do enough of it and
with with it with it with it with a
teacher who is harsh enough I mean I can
to think that probably in an academic
setting nobody is as harsh as as people
are in a perfectly in a professional
setting
I think I got a I think I got I myself
was probably better off at loves and I
would have been in graduate school but
that's a that's a personal thing I mean
I I don't think I had it in me to get as
much to take as much away from graduate
from a full graduate program we haven't
talked a lot about Miami what why did
you want to write about this I had
wanted to do something about the
American connection was the Caribbean
ever since basically ever since the
Kennedy assassination I mean I started
seeing is at a time when everybody was
saying the wave of we could see America
we could read America America's future
was being lived today in California I
didn't think it was I thought America's
future was being lived today on the
southern border specifically not so much
the Texas border but specifically it's
because the interface was a Caribbean
and was with with Latin America and so
at some point when it was I became
interested in the Cuban community in in
Miami and went down and did this I spent
some time there and again and I still
think that that community is not very
well understood the extent to which it
in Washington have got each other's
fantasies for
ever since ever since basically ever
since the exile began I mean it's a
whole interesting thing we saw a lot of
it play out in the Elian Gonzalez story
anything about that that struck you
pulling a lot of things that struck me
with um one was that that right there it
was it was one of one of the most potent
exile ideas or myths he had to do with
with saving children there was in the
60s a lot of children were sent from
from from Cuba to Miami under something
called he was run by the archdiocese by
the Catholic Archdiocese of Miami of
South Florida it was something called
Operation Peter Pan and or Pedro Pan and
the children were being brought to
Miami's because there was a rumor in
Cuba that children would be sent to
school and to live in in in school
situations in forced to go to school
situations in the Soviet Union so
instead they were taken from their
parents and sent to our their parents we
actually ran to the airport to put them
on planes to Miami and in many cases
didn't see them again for a long time so
this is 7 is it was a very potent story
in the exile mind that was one thing the
other thing was it got politicized by
all sides you know and it was it was it
was just it I would love to have gone
down and and actually looked into it
some more but I cuz I couldn't in terms
of time I was doing something else
ok next hello hi my name is Martha and
I'm IQ an American I came to the United
States in 1961 and you sort of answered
my question regarding why or even how
you penetrated the
the the cuban-american community and
interestingly enough in your book Miami
I know some of the people that you
mentioned mm-hmm and my my question is
well just sort of like a comment I
returned to Cuba after 38 years and
unbeknownst to my parents because that's
like being a traitor to my own people
but I sort of think that we as Cubans
and Cuban Americans are sort of either
we talk a lot but we we don't have the
guts
either we're not courageous enough or we
don't have the balls
excuse the word to really do something
effective and re-establish a somewhat
democratic government in Cuba and that
we have lived with this you know we're
with this tragedy for so for so long and
I'll take your comments or your thoughts
of the year
thank you have you lived did you live in
Miami no well ya know what yeah yes I
did live in Miami I lived in Miami from
1975 to 1978 and I was raised in Chicago
and I nonino Lavinia Lavinia do you
mentioning right yeah and Raul and and
well and yeah well anyway so I sort of
always looked at Miami from the outside
because I I went back in my 20s and then
I left and I even felt always like an
outsider in Miami and I've lived in
Chicago and and the West Coast in the
last 15 years
thanks Phoenix I think I would be
interested in knowing how many Cuban
Americans I mean I think there's a whole
feel like outsiders
I think there's business there's a whole
and there's now a whole a whole lot of
but there always has been a lot of
brand of opinion in the community but it
isn't always expressed in public connect
today New York yeah hi I'm a college
professor and I've taught your novels
are and several times in many graduate
courses art what Salvador democracy and
I play to delays and a chapter of one of
my books is devoted to democracy and I'm
one of the things I want to ask you that
the review was found at a very difficult
book and I think it's what they keep the
books of the post Cold War era I think
it's what is really a classic do you
have trouble finding appropriate
audience for difficult books I mean in
certain ways you know Eliot and pound
glossed each other so that they could
find their own audiences and there I
don't think they're enough people
glossing you and are you disappointed
that that book didn't get the kind of
audience it might have did you say your
name was David Thompson no my name
Valentino oh I am you can't be
disappointed you're delighted when
somebody when somebody gets it I mean
when somebody responds and cares about
it it's like I don't I don't I don't I
don't somebody everybody took from that
novel different things some people
thought as a romance pure and simple
some people saw were interested in the
fictional tricks in it I mean it was I
think it's I think it's sort of more
difficult and bicha said that was one of
your more difficult was difficult for me
yeah San Jose hello hi I needed purposes
by saying that I'm a huge fan and
slouching towards Bethlehem was a
touchstone book in my life but I was
wondering being married to another
writer does define this helps you or
hinders you this you stay out of his way
or do you help each other when you stuck
something wrong no I actually it's been
a huge help it's been a huge help both
in in getting a
Oh support a very possible kind I mean
financial support to people might not
have had been it had quite the nerve to
try to support yourself just just make
just writing or I if there weren't two
of us but are you ever entered intersect
me out of what you're writing and how it
what you mean the right away we read it
yes we edit it we always read ideas we
always read it it depends on different
points and different projects and
depends on what yeah and talk about it
we don't give each other ideas so much
he has certain kinds of ideas are more
likely to occur to him and other kinds
of ideas are more likely to occur to me
but I mean we're totally and think at
the time during the work process your
husband's best-known book well might
what my best is his best best book is
book is always the book he's working on
but he but true confessions the red
white and blue and then monster is last
non-fiction book was very Oklahoma City
hello go ahead
this is Edith Smith and I wanted to ask
a question a book that I read reread
about once a year is a Book of Common
Prayer and I don't hear it discussed
that might tell though I might have
missed it in the early part of this
program but it seems to me a perfectly
written book and I wondered a if it had
been a book that sort of just sort of
wrote itself easily because it seems to
so absolutely perfect in terms of the
way it is written in the characters and
secondly I was so fascinated by the
voice the persona of grace and I
wondered how much of that is at was
actually your own voice I did write that
book easily for one thing I was teaching
at Berkley for a month or so
during during a hard time in it I mean
during the time when a book either has
to turn into you know to take off or not
take off and I was I was living in a
room with the Faculty Club by myself all
during the week so gave me this it was a
really good time to I had a lot of time
to simply by myself to simply
concentrate on the thing so it was
really good
nobody was calling me up the the
character of grace came out of a lot of
things and obviously everybody obviously
some of her voice is mine but but I
posited her somewhat older older than I
was at the time although I that was a
that was one of those books that I it
was a famous thing of George Eliot
saying that she'd begun some book as a
young woman and ended an old woman and I
felt bad about about a Book of Common
Prayer for some reason it just took
forever but it was easy to write I mean
it was easy to write in that sense I had
a lot of fun with look in the title
essay for the White Album look you start
by saying we tell ourselves stories in
order to live right and then later you
say at least or at least we do for a
while we talk about a period in which
you had a problem with your writing this
was just it was a period in the 60s when
I began to doubt the stories I told
myself doubt the narrative um so if you
don't have you know a strong sense of
what things are about you can't write
you wrote this and just to give people
an idea of what you were going through
at the time you say my entire education
everything I had ever been told or had
told myself insisted that the production
was never meant to be improvised I was
supposed to have a script and had
mislaid it I was supposed to hear cues
and no longer did I was meant to know
the plot how did you get out of that
I worked my way out of it actually I
think I think I got out of it with with
we played as it lays because plays I
mean I started in that mood and then I
finished it and immediately my felt
better
it was next to Santa Rosa California
hello said Rosa Gerald thank you so much
for being here this show what I wanted
to do is say I've read all of your books
that I don't buy and love them and what
I'd actually like to do is ask about a
couple of your contemporary writers and
opinion reaction whatever you want to
say but those two people I also like are
Tom Wolfe and Diane Johnson well they're
both friends so I'm not going to I'm in
a deficit they're both I mean Denney
especially I'm crazy about and and Tom
are known since since since you know
since we were both babies um how's that
well everybody just knew each other you
know has to front of the hotel I mean I
don't mean baby really truly babies and
I since we were young yeah do you
remember what how you would intersect
your license I on remember I just
remember I'm coming to the first house
we had in California those that was
right when he was a reporter I think he
was working for the Herald Tribune then
yeah mmm
New Haven Connecticut hi good afternoon
the city and I read Miami and I'm
totally captivated by it and I saw
somewhere a reference to your essay on
self-respect but I'm not able to find it
I'm hoping we can vary which bucket said
I think I suppose I think it's in them
the white album is that possible admit
it on time well are we slouching towards
Bethlehem so not take
take a look you could say briefly what
the essay aims to do anything
accomplished you may not see us any
respect
yes self-respect is in flashing towards
us it is okay see do you mean what what
what that particular as they try to
accomplish I think that's what she was
being direct yeah all right well I don't
know it was just I I mean I couldn't
even say what I was trying to accomplish
because the circumstances are so we
wrapped up in how as I explained them
and being asked to do this or having to
do it in in essence and naturally it
expresses what I thought but it's but
but but I was inviting it in too much of
a rush they have any actual intention
for it I think first paragraph goes like
this once in a dry season I wrote a
large in large letters across two pages
of a notebook that innocence ends when
one is stripped of the delusion that one
likes oneself although now some years
later I marvel that a mind on the outs
with itself it should have nonetheless
made painstaking record of its every
turmoil I recall with embarrassing
clarity the flavor of those particular
ashes it has a matter of misplaced
self-respect
it was also a part where you wrote on
that was right in the area where you
wrote on going home on morality yeah for
those which you gathered in that in the
area in this one because they were all
personal pieces as opposed to reporting
Boulder Colorado hello yes you're on the
air man go ahead I would just like to
tell miss city and I'm a fan of her
husband's book harp I really like that
no I quite a bit but I wish you could
speak to communications with your
readers like letters and I don't know if
you have email or not but um do you like
to receive them and they responded and
ever personally sometimes sometimes I do
sometimes but I have it
I don't get email I mean because I can't
bear to have things up coming in onto my
working screen you know when I when I'm
working things that come in the mail I'm
always delighted to get and I always
mean to answer but sometimes they pile
up like with a bunch of business letters
and stuff I mean things things I don't
actually correspond with anybody when
I'm working so so it's so I correspond
with people at these erratic intervals
so that's you mentioned earlier that you
had a lot of mail after the essay on my
grades what else has gendered a lot of
damn um that I think the most and then
then something else it did was totally
out of the blue to me was sort of a just
a nothing piece it was it food to read
the review of a footy Alan that I did
for the New York Review and I got a
tremendous amount of mail on that from I
don't know I seem to be a lot of movie
buffs out there you know one way or the
other
next is Minneapolis hello hello miss
Didion uh I'm a huge fan of course along
with a young doctor from Montreal dr.
Carl Gutierrez we we swear by slouching
towards Bethlehem our question what in
the hell ever happened to Lucille
Maxwell Miller did you ever get an
update of her from some dreamers from
the Golden Land
who is she caller first of all tell us
who she is very much like Clinton and
other stories by your husband and what
did you think of Pauline Kael labeling
you the High Priestess of angst thank
you very much as Jim Seberg well the
last question first I didn't realize
that she had that following kill had
labeled me too high but people are
always saying angst about me so so so
much device you know actually I'm quite
a cheerful versus perfect see what
happened to Lucille Miller's I went to
prison
and then she got out of prison and then
I believe she later died and this was
that in one of your essays about wasn't
this is in some dreamers of the golden
dream she it was convicted of of killing
her husband he mentioned your daughter
again and I noticed that you have
dedicated a lot of your books yeah her
because she's the one who had to put up
with me writing them and she and John
yes yes he comes up often why did it
yeah and then after Henry obviously was
dedicated to Henry Rollins it rellis
Henry Robin Roberts excuse me but you
also dedicate this to Bret Easton Ellis
who met he's a he's a young writer he's
a friend of someone actually he's a
little older than my daughter Bret
Easton Ellis you know who is this
American Psycho kind of American Psycho
yeah who was having you know a lot of
trouble heaps going through the period
on American Psycho where he was having a
lot of getting a lot of non faith from
his publisher and so we talked about
various yeah San Francisco yes the city
and it's a pleasure to speak with you
I first read the White Album many years
ago and was blown away by the directness
and real excitement of your style and
I've been a corporate writer all of my
life and have tried to write fiction at
various times and I'm very intrigued
with the fact that you are a successful
writer in both fiction and nonfiction
and when you were talking earlier about
how before you read a novel you read
victory by Joseph Conrad or the good
soldier by forbidding Ford is this how
you sort of get your mind into the
fictive voice how did you find a voice
for fiction when you're such a
wonderfully direct nonfiction writer I
wrote fiction before I wrote nonfiction
so the voice I had was a fiction voice
and I don't know that that's what I
noticed the difference in the voice is
that I notice is my the voice I use in
fiction the voice that feels right in
fiction has a lot it's almost them has a
lot of rhythm and it's like a tiger it's
like that it's like the liturgy it's
like a lot of repetition very simple
sentences with a very few clauses in
nonfiction there's a lot of there a lot
of clauses and kind of densely it gets
denser and denser in fact I don't much
you know I'm not going to make it make
it simple it seems to me to take you can
you can I somehow you can get a lot more
authority and I mean it and you can make
it kind of come alive that way do you
ever get criticized for it yeah oh yeah
all the time
in fact and I mean even it as it appears
in magazines that is not even as dense
as if as it went in because quite often
I will have to cut a sentence in half
because it feels an entire column yeah
but okay wait is it okay for a reader
when they get to that something like
that to have to read it a couple times
the mug you mind oh no I think you have
to to get it but also I mean it's
somehow I keep thinking that you could
probably contain a whole a whole piece
you could probably balance a whole piece
in some synthesis you know which is sort
of an interesting I mean it's sort of an
exciting idea in me Miami go ahead
well let me hit mine let me hit my
muting but please first of all let me
say that I just love in depth this is
such a wonderful thing to be able to
have someone like Joan Didion on for
three hours I don't know how she's
standing it but she seems to be holding
up very well thank you
like she is but
anyway I really appreciate it even
though book TV and in-depth cuts an
awful lot into my work time it's worth
it but I wanted to I'm from Miami I'm an
old Miami in fact older than I'd like to
admit my family's been here hundred
years and I think our book was just
marvelous on it this is such a complex
society that's society with a small F
down here we all are amazed those of us
who are born and raised here the people
haven't quite figured out that there's
the city of Miami
there's Greater Miami there's Miami
Beach and they're all different and they
keep lumping us all together and I'm
non-latin but have I have my cup of
Cuban coffee at a latte every every more
it's so addictive isn't it
that bekaert is so addictive isn't it
what yes and yes but it's so good yeah
and the company is great and I tell you
when your shoulder to shoulder with all
of the characters and I don't mean that
pejoratively when your shoulder to
shoulder at the coffee window with all
of the characters in this ongoing
adventure story it's so rather
interesting I love Miami it just feels I
feel I feel kind of excited as if
anything can happen every day I'm there
in San Diego hi my name is Alan cravat
I'm a student at San Diego State
University and in two of my literature
classes we read play it as it lays I
absolutely adored the book okay the
biggest question on my mind after I read
the book was how you felt about the
character of Malaya how did I feel about
Mariah well I mean I got Mariah was
Mariah I couldn't I couldn't analyze how
I felt about her I mean I I you know
she's there she's there on the page I I
can't really analyze how I feel about
her you had long I love all of my care
you do you know more attached to some
than others
wilmer ion with - - I'm a 10 - I'm
attached to all of them
you know all the major characters
anybody in the nonfiction world that you
became very attached to the nonfiction
is different because you don't you're
out of here that you're at a distance
from them you're not you wouldn't you
wouldn't you wouldn't intrude that much
you know so it's no and you don't become
attached that way
Chicago hello yes sir miss Diddy and I
wrote an essay by your about 40 years
ago in the National Review concerning
the John Wayne's movie the Alamo canyons
with they don't make him like Duke on
the new frontier I was wondering when
did you move from right to left what was
the process I know it I'm not sure that
I moved from right to left oh I moved
from what was yeah yeah I did
it was it I think it happened during the
after the Goldwater I thought I you know
I thought I bought it for Barry
Goldwater and then and anyone given much
support in I noticed in California when
I was out there and the party didn't
backing and they then did back Ronald
Reagan which has you know as far as I
was concerned they they had not done the
right thing so I kind of started moving
then and then I was you know it made me
feel good when um I I started I don't
think that the business that I mean I I
didn't have any I I was registered as a
Republican until I wanted to vote for Oh
Jerry Brown is for governor of
California so I registered as a Democrat
I want to vote in a primary so that was
what do you think it's Bill Clinton well
I
I voted for him the second time I didn't
vote for him the first time the reason I
voted for him the second time was I
thought I thought he was not only the
luckiest man alive and he could carry
that luck with him but he was doing a
you know he was he was ok there was a
supers
I didn't I still think he could be
elected to a circus Lee he could be
elected to a third term if he could run
you have reviewed Michael Isikoff the
book on President Clinton what do you
think about all of these books not
Jeffrey Toobin book was quite good we
got just read a couple months ago I
guess when I was quite followed and very
interesting from the music off book I
didn't I thought wasn't quite straight
so in terms of of where he stood in
relation to them to the material next
Santacruz hello I'm is Diddy and I'm a
big fan of yours as well read most of
your work and I too moved to New York in
1988 and have recently returned to
California I was interested in what you
perceived California now I know you live
in New York but I assume you still make
trips home occasionally and I was
wondering what you think about the
direction California has taken thank you
or calm I'm not sure that I'm that I
expected that I even know what direction
it's taken that's one of the things I
want to get into what a lot of people
who live in California is complaints
about California don't seem to me
totally I mean for example I keep
hearing from everybody I know in Los
Angeles about the traffic right hamsa
traffic I mean I was there two weeks ago
the traffic is not at five o'clock in
the afternoon getting from Lum getting
from Mahon and you know in East
Hollywood to
to Santa Monica in half-an-hour seem not
terribly demanding so I don't know quite
I think there's a certain
dissatisfaction among some people in
California with the way things are going
but what they mean by that I don't know
in the White Album you have an essay on
called good citizens it was written in
the late 60s where you're talking about
being invited to a civil rights meeting
it's Sammy Davis jr. house
you wrote politics are not widely
considered a legitimate source of
amusement in Hollywood where the
borrowed rhetoric by which political
ideas are reduced to choices between the
good equality is good and the bad
genocide is bad tends to make even the
most casual political small talk
resemble a rally set true today that's
true and he's still true actually to
people things that Hollywood is infused
with politics politics is infused in
telling what has been ever since I went
out there but I mean in 64 I mean
difference we always been everybody's
been very involved in politics but it's
not very it is rather retort rather more
rhetorical then so some people are not
rhetorical some people are really keyed
in but um but the sort of Road
involvement is it's not is not is not
it's more shallow than deployments in
Oklahoma City next yes I want to thank
you for c-span and what an honor to
listen to Joan Didion and see her I just
want to say that I think miss Didion's
may be the finest living writer in
America today and read almost all her
books and the one that I found was most
powerful was Salvador and I wonder if
there's any chance that you think about
writing again about Central America it's
become even more ambiguous it seems to
me and has kind of fallen off the
american map and i'm not sure that it
has any has fallen off the american map
it always falls off the american math
unless we can Leslie unless we're
involved in something I mean unless the
unless we have some kind of action there
going on
I don't
basically salvador was about was about
washington more than it was about
salvador and so i I wouldn't I wouldn't
dream that I could write a book about a
Central American or a South American
country in the absence I mean I can only
look at it from from from from the
American perspective
I couldn't get inside the culture I
don't think the fish I mean I wouldn't I
don't think that any American could La
Jolla California hi this is John
Christianson and we have a technical
question for you is there's a little
trick in writing fiction whereby one is
able to smooth out the dialogue when one
character speaks to another without
saying he said she says it yeah you just
is just a little practice you just do it
I mean you just try doing it you can do
it you can use you but you don't have to
use he said she said every time and you
know but you have to use them once in a
while to keep the reader oriented you
just get used to this I'm sorry hit go
ahead manehattan go ahead New York
hello hi I'm a justice out inarticulate
as Miss Didion because of a neurological
disorder however I am NOT unintelligent
I'm an old friend I was an old
acquaintance of Harriet done at the time
around the time you got married I'm
almost crying watching you however she
is not here now and I think it's very
fortunate all I'll say is it but a guy
from a young man from West Hartford
married a young woman from California
what's her name Dianne Cary Diane Dallas
Carrie ah I knew her Harriet had a mock
sense of humor funny funny and I hope it
you do too and your husband he must have
I think yeah it couldn't be it done with
that one yeah that's all I have so
thanks for I can't talk to you this
would have been your husband's first
wife no that's me you're talking about
Harriet is his sister his sister yummy
next is Michigan hi hi miss Didion yeah
I'm calling from a Houghton Michigan I'm
going to actually just read book for my
college literature class a small place
by Jamaica Kincaid and I heard you make
a comment earlier that you're interested
in the American ties to the Caribbean
and I just wanted to know your general
you know comment on that subject and if
what your views of the book were and how
it spoke on the conditions and kind of
the culture down there now her book is
about the Caribbean mine by my interest
was in the American interface political
interface with the Caribbean um nothing
I mean the Caribbean per se was and
isn't is another subject in a Jamaica
Kincaid we have just a few minutes left
what would kind of advice would you give
to people who are out there trying to
stop getting those letters of rejection
I guess you know the people who have
already written people who have things
in their hands but can't seem to get
through the process you just have to try
something else you could try my don't
mean try another it'd be to try and
write something else coming up from
having comments that's a comment come up
to the task of being a writer from a
different I mean you know the Rytas that
writes another thing try to tell that
then maybe you can see ways to ways to
rewrite or make the other thing to make
the first thing work I don't it's not
it's not an easy thing to do what do you
think about the state of the publishing
industry today well it's practically one
hell everything lots of consolidation
yeah
lot of laws and I don't think it will
ultimately be good for it but we'll see
that's the if the future of the book in
electronics or are we going to stay
people say that I'm not reading what I
was reading in the paper one of the
papers this morning about somebody
reading an entire book on on a Palm
Pilot uh-huh would you ever do that what
I ever read an entire book on a Palm
Pilot
oh no I wouldn't but who knows I thought
would have thought I wouldn't use a
computer to Colorado Springs hello
yes Chi Minh City and I think you're
fascinating I'm not familiar with your
work but actually I would like to be
after today so I'm wondering if you
could tell me possibly what would be of
all your works what would you recommend
my first book of yours be that I read
well I would say dodging toward death
ahem only because it has a piece in it
which has which the piece is about John
Wayne with that is the point this but
it's the beginning of it takes takes
place in Colorado Springs Pacific Ocean
so maybe there was something actually
that's a perfect entree in the
minute-and-a-half we have left to just
kind of walk through the ten books the
five is in nonfiction five section and
if you could just give us a very general
overview of what people would find in
then let's start with slouching towards
Bethlehem dodging towards Bethlehem
they're all pieces that I wrote in the
60s there um it wasn't the main piece is
about it's about the haight-ashbury in
1967 after headmaster Henry the main
piece is about the New York Central Park
jogger and then there other pieces about
Californian about the White Album the
White Album the main piece is actually
looking back at the 60s it's it's about
that whole period at the very end of the
60s in Los Angeles Miami
Miami's about the Exile community in
Miami and its relationship with
Washington and Salvador
Salvador's about the American assistance
effort there in nineteen the 80s and
it's connection with Washington and then
moving to the fiction the last thing he
wanted that's my iran-contra novel and
you have to read it in one sitting
because it's got so much plot one said a
crew yeah
Book of Common Prayer Book of Common
Prayer is sinful American novel it takes
place in the country not on I mean just
he wasn't the author Alberto had never
been to El Salvador and I wrote it but
it was country not totally unlike run
River Runner was a really traditional
now it was my first novel I wanted to
make it a little more cut up the time
sequence but I didn't know how to do it
well enough and so so basically I had to
put it all back in a conventional frame
so it's a very conventional novel about
color conventional it was about a hop
growers adulterous wife in the
Sacramento Valley but that's about a
family democracy in Lok Rafi is I think
of as my novel about the fall of Saigon
it would be a good novel to read this
during this week because tied into all
that film we've been looking at again on
television and plays that play it as it
lays plain as it lays is just is about
someone going through an emotional
crisis in height of an actress going
through an emotional crisis you know
it's about it's a book about white space
it's very under there very understated
book a minute to move fast and it does
huh it's a it was it was it's a less
complex book in a lot of ways and the
other ones I should say about democracy
by the way it's about the follows I'm
going to take it to I think of it as the
fall of Saigon both but it that that
barely happens unit it all takes it has
to do with a murder in Honolulu what's
next I don't know I mean I'm working on
I want to do this California thing and
then I'm and then I'm surge starting
another novel so nonfiction next
probably you and then another fiction
well yeah we how many have left in you I
don't know I don't know if I'm lucky
Joan Didion thank you so much for
spending three hours with us on you got
to appreciate it
if you'd like to see our in-depth
interview with Joan Didion again join us
tonight at midnight eastern nine Pacific
will carry the three hour program in its
entirety here on book TV in-depth book
td's live series looking at the work of
prolific